Vor allen Dingen haben wir noch viel größere Probleme, als dass wir zu spät dran sind. Wir haben nämlich unsere Intro-Musik nicht mit. Deswegen jetzt der Aufruf an euch zu Hause. Es gibt bestimmt irgendjemand, der das mal aufgezeichnet hat. Wir müssen das telefonisch heute machen. Unsere Telefonnummer ist 0331 für Potsdam 7097110. Wir suchen jemand, der den Chaosradio Jingle und die Kraftwerkmusik, die wir immer zu Beginn dieser Sendung spielen, jetzt griffbereit hat, uns anruft und uns das Ganze dann über Telefon hier rein gibt. Ihr wisst, die 0331 ist die bekannte Vorwahl der Telekom, die dann dafür sorgt, dass Fritz alle Kosten übernimmt. Jeder Anruf nach Potsdam geht eigentlich zu Lasten von Fritz. Nein, das ist natürlich nicht so, aber wenn ihr zum Beispiel aus Berlin anruft, ist das ein Stadtgespräch, ein Ortsgespräch. Aber wie heißt das? Keine Ahnung. Und wieso ist das in der Richtung? Und deswegen braucht ihr euch dann um die Kosten erst mal keine Sorgen machen. Mal gucken, ob wir überhaupt jemanden finden, der das hat.
Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Du bist das nicht. Ist da unten ein Fan geben, der das aufgenommen hat? Die Mikros müssen ja auch nicht an sein, weil ich hab euch ja überhaupt noch nicht angesagt und vorgestellt. Willst du schon was sagen, Andi?
Ja, nee, ich dachte wir können ja auch sonst erst mal die Ersatz-Intro-Musik, die wir da mitgebracht haben.
Hast du das Intro?
Kannst du das vorspielen?
Die Verbindung wird gehalten.
Ach komm, wir machen doch Musik vom Plattenteller erst mal, wenn das so nicht klappt.
Wir sind die Basen.
Ein verspätetes Herzlich Willkommen zum Chaosradio.
Kommt Junta Blumun bei Fritz jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat.
Die Musik, die ihr hört, kommt mal wieder vom Analog Club DJ Team, aber live diesmal.
Premiere, sonst von der Konserve. Und heute sind sie beide hier zum ersten Mal live zu Gast in der Sendung. Ganz herzlich Willkommen, können gar nicht antworten, weil sie haben kein Mikro, aber die anderen haben alle ein Mikro. Dann gibt's den berühmt berüchtigten Mikrocheck.
Was ich verstehen könnte, Tim ist heute nicht hier, stattdessen fast fast irgendwie sehr ungewöhnliches Team.
Sag mal kurz an, wer das da ist. Naja, Steini ist da.
Und die Anke?
Steini und Andi kennt er, Frank war ganz am Anfang mal hier. Und Anke ist völlig zum ersten Mal hier, ne? Und vor allen Dingen deswegen zusätzliche Weltpremiere, weil zum ersten Mal mit einer Frau vom Chaos Computer Club hier. Ja, muss halt blöderweise doch immer noch mal dazu sagen. Warum bist du nicht öfter dabei?
Weil es nicht immer um nicht-technisches geht.
Wie, es geht um nicht-technisches heute? Kannst du mal was zum Thema sagen?
Technik und Schulen, das ist doch...
Ja, und ich bin zu den Schulen zuständig.
An welchem Knopf hängst denn du?
Du musst doch mal in dieses Mikro sprechen.
Nee, nee, das tut er schon, aber... Warte mal, du bist da, das Mikrofon hat hier...
Also meins scheint zu... Warte mal, hier ist vielleicht ein Wacklaut. Sagt doch mal was. Sprecht doch mal so Sätze in dieses Mikrofon.
Nee, nee, der hängt am falschen Kabel. Wir machen das gleich nochmal.
Warte mal, hier ist...
Wir sortieren uns hier mal in Ruhe, ne?
Einer von euch beiden hat den Kopfhörer, der da unten reingeht, stimmt's?
Hier leuchtet eine rote Lampe, Johnny.
Den Kopfhörer musst du Frank geben.
Warum denn?
Ich will aber das behalten. Könnt ihr nicht in der Mitte beide da reinquatschen? Warum denn nicht? Das Kabel hier ist total schief. Wir schieben jetzt einfach das Mikro hier rüber und schon ist es in Ordnung. Jetzt quatscht ihr beide in das Mikro und alles bin gut.
Die Leute denken immer, wir wären so chaotisch. Das Problem ist tatsächlich, wir kommen ja in dieses Studio erst wirklich so um kurz vor 10 rein und deswegen hat man für so was wie Mikrochecks, weil die eine Sendung ja immer noch läuft, dann können wir nicht den Jungs irgendwie die Mikros mitnehmen.
Wie machen das eigentlich die anderen?
Die anderen haben nicht 6 Leute im Studio.
Wollt ihr das höher haben? Wer stellt denn jetzt eigentlich das Thema vor? Das ist die Frage, die ich auch gerade gemacht habe.
Ich stell mal das Thema vor. Ich nehm das mal in die Hand, werden ihr hier noch basteln. Das Thema ist Medienkompetenz und Schulen. Es geht also im Wesentlichen darum, dass ihr, ihr armen Schüler, eigentlich genau wisst, was man mit dieser ultra-entgeilen Hardware alles machen kann und dieser super abgefahrenen Software. Und dass das, genau das, was ihr wollt, in den Schulen nicht passiert. Und dass ihr eigentlich viel mehr wissen wollt und eigentlich viel mehr erfahren wollt von euren Lehrern. Die sind aber total betröttelt. Und dass ihr Lehrer davon leider überhaupt keinen blassen Schimmer habt. Und das dann auch den Schülern gar nicht beibringen können. Und warum das nicht gut ist und was man da machen kann und wie das eigentlich real aussieht, darüber wollen wir heute reden.
Das war's im Jahr 1993. Fischmop unter der Leitung von Bolles mit der Dänemark.
Wir führen euch alle ganz normal nochmal ganz langsam das Thema ein.
Genau.
Schule, da haben jetzt wahrscheinlich die meisten sowieso schon ausgescheitert.
Ja, was Steinle da eben in einer Jugendradio-Sender kompatiblen Sprache zu vermitteln versuchte, war das Thema der heutigen Sendung. Wir wollen reden über, tja, Schulen, Du bist ja eher so ein motivierender Mensch, ne? und Computer und Vernetzung und dann gibt's noch so Begriffe wie Medienkompetenz. Also es soll ein bisschen um das Dilemma gehen, die zeitgemäßen Fähigkeiten mit den Medien unserer Zeit umzugehen, ja, zu erlernen. Wir haben aber ein bisschen das Problem, dass theoretisch in der Schule das immer so läuft, dass die Lehrer den Schülern was erklären, aber im Zeitalter des Internets und was die Materie Internet betrifft, kann es wenn überhaupt wahrscheinlich ohnehin nur andersrum laufen. Da gibt's so ein paar Generationsprobleme. Aber gut, wir haben uns ein paar Gedanken gemacht und zur Abwechslung haben wir uns auch mal vorbereitet und Frank hat da so eine Art Struktur, wie wir euch durch diese dreistündige Sendung so führen wollen.
Genau, das wäre natürlich, wo es am schönsten wäre, wenn wirklich Lehrer und Schüler dann zuhören und vielleicht nachher dann auch ein bisschen anrufen, da wären die...
Genau, wir wollen euer Feedback.
Wir haben auf jeden Fall Erfahrungen von beiden Seiten interessant. Richtig, wir werden euch jetzt erst mal so erzählen, wo wir dann so die Probleme sehen und wie dann so die ganze Materie beschaffen ist. Danach, dann im zweiten Teil, das ist also nach den Nachrichten, da gehen wir dann so ein bisschen auf den aktuellen Stand ein. Das heißt, wie viele Computer gibt es eigentlich so in den Schulen? Was für Computer stehen da vor allem? Was mit den Computern gemacht wird? Und wir wollen auch natürlich von euch wissen, was ihr denn im Unterricht mit den Dingern macht, was die Lehrer mit euch machen wollen. Da gibt es dann so Begriffe wie Schullands Netz und offenes deutsches Schulnetz. Und da wollen wir ein bisschen drüber reden. Im nächsten Teil geht es dann so um Linux kontra Standardprogramme. Also Standardprogramme sind dann so vielleicht das Office-Paket von unserer geliebten Firma Microsoft. Und da wollen wir dann mal drüber nachdenken, ob das denn so klug ist, die Leute dann wirklich mit diesem einen Betriebssystem, mit diesem einem Office-Paket so aufs Berufsleben vorzubereiten. Und im vierten Teil, das ist dann so der letzte Teil hinten dran, da werden wir dann so ein bisschen rumvisionieren und mal überlegen, ob wir eigentlich noch Lehrer brauchen oder ob die Schüler denn in der Schule noch Lehrer brauchen oder ob man das eigentlich auf eine ganz andere Basis stellen sollte.
Oder um es mit den Worten von dem noch Bundespräsident Herzog zu sagen, es hängt viel von der Kompetenz der Generation ab, ob das Medium wieder zu einer Verdummung, wie seinerzeit beim Fernsehen führt.
Das alles im Chaosradio heute hier mit dem Chaos Computer Club und mit dem Analog Club DJ Team und mit Johnny. Ihr könnt euch über die Sendung unterhalten. Es gibt im IRC, soweit ich weiß, einen Kanal der Chaos Radio heißt. Ansonsten gibt es auch bei Fritz einen Webchat. Das ist ein Java-basierter Chat. Da müsst ihr also Java haben, der ist zu finden unter www.fritz.de slash V-Chat, also V-Chat in einem Wort. Da sind auch schon einige Leute anwesend. Was ist mit Real Audio? Ja, keine Ahnung, konnte ich vorher auch nicht mehr checken. Wenn es Real Audio gibt, findet man den Link eigentlich immer gleich auf der Startpage, nämlich unter www.fritz.de. Ansonsten hat einer von euch im Kopf immer wieder Link, weil ich glaube einfach nur www.fritz.de slash live-ramm oder live-raam.
Du meinst diesen Chat da, diesen ärstlichen Chat?
Hey, ich mein, seid medienkompetent, findet das selber raus.
Genau, wir brauchen keine Lehre.
Mach mal Alterwister, ey. Ruf doch mal einer an, sag mal ey.
Ich ruf nicht an.
Hat irgendjemand von euch in seiner Schulzeit mit Computern zu tun gehabt? Also ich meine jetzt nicht privat, sondern in der Schule.
Das sagen wir jetzt nicht.
Also ich hab meinen ersten Schulrauswurf so arrangiert bekommen. Es gab da irgendwie einen Computerraum, wo es immerhin, so das war 1984 rum, da gab es zwei Commodore, so 4032, das sind so, also 40, bezieht sich glaube ich auf 40 Zeichen pro Zeile und 32 Kilobyte RAM. Kilobyte, wogemeint, nicht Megabyte, ja. Und da konnte man dann irgendwie in der Pause Space Invaders spielen und Basic programmieren und all so ein Zeug machen und man konnte das auch am Nachmittag und man konnte das auch zwischendurch.
Ich hab Pascal gelernt auf dem Apple II.
Hat einer von euch auch so eine Computer Benutzungserlaubnis Prüfung gemacht? Dann hat er so einen Persilschein bekommen, dass man weiß, dass man da, wenn man da drauf rumhackt, keinen Beil und keinen Hammer nimmt, sondern die Finger in die Tessatur und so und dann hat man wie ein kurzes Basic Programm ein Schachbrennmuster auf dem Bildschirm und so. Ich hab diesen bisschen. Und dann durfte ich selbst stetig zum Hausmeister gehen und mir den Schein von Computer, den Schlüssel von Computer holen.
So was kann wieder einführen, so ein Computerführerschein.
Computerführerschein.
Das ist so was wie Fahrradführerschein.
Datenautobahnführerschein.
Könnt ihr machen, in Berlin.
Und wenn man dann geblitzt wird, wie ist das denn Anke, was passiert dann?
Das weiß ich nicht, da musst du die Medienwerkstatt Hollywood fragen.
Wie wie wie Hollywood oder was?
Weiß ich nicht, die nehme ich an. Die leisten Führerscheine, du kannst da hingehen, du kannst Kurse machen und dann hast du einen Internet-Führerschein, den gibt es da. Den gibt es bestimmt auch noch in anderen Ecken, aber da gibt es den sicher.
Der Wahnsinn, aber ich bin irgendwie noch nie im Internet nach einem Führerschein gefragt worden. So ein Schwein aber auch.
Das liegt vielleicht daran, daß die Funkwagen nicht so schnell hinter dir her kommen.
Die haben halt keine Porsches.
Ich bin wahrscheinlich ein Stückchen älter als ihr. Ich war bei uns an der Schule von Computern weiter und breit nicht zu sehen.
Wie alt bist du nur, Johnny?
34.
Ach, so viel älter bist du.
Da hat der Schwein gehabt. Also ich weiß, das ist mein C64-Kamera-Haus. Ich glaube, als ich 18 oder 19 war in dem Dreh. Ich glaube, mein Jahrgang war der erste, die damals diesen ITG-Unterricht gehabt haben, oder einer der ersten Jahrgänge. ITG, Informationstechnische Grundbildung.
Hey, cool, kann noch jemand einen Bass dazu singen? Und was heißt das? Informationstechnische Grundbildung?
Wir haben da sogar einen Rotonsu, das heißt, wir waren heute mal ganz fleißig und haben sogar mal ein bisschen was vorbereitet für die Sendung. Und da haben wir auch einen Lehrer dazu, wo wir vielleicht schon gerade dabei sind. Und vielleicht, wenn wir den Titel... Welchen denn? Da, wo ITG dransteht. Vier. Gute Idee. Machen wir mal vier. Ach so, du hast den Zettel jetzt gar nicht mehr. Ich hab den Zettel ja.
Dann nimm du den und zeig mir immer mit dem Finger, an welcher es dann ist.
Genau, ich hab nämlich mal so einen ITG-Lehrer, den Hans-Berner von der Bornbier-Oberschule, gefragt, was denn da bei ihm in unserem ITG-Unterricht passiert.
Der ITG-Unterricht soll Schülern der 8. Klasse in erster Linie Grundbedienung am Rechner vermitteln. Und zwar nicht nur, dass sie den Rechner bedienen können, sondern dass sie ihn einsetzen als Werkzeug. Das bezieht sich eben nicht nur auf Textprogramme und Tabellenkalkulationen, das bezieht sich auch auf Maschinensteuerung. Wir haben an den Gesamtschulen meistens eine computergestellte Fräse. Die Schüler können dann an dem Rechner ein Programm bedienen, einen Verfahrenweg eigenprogrammieren und dann unten in der Werkstatt die Sache an der Fräse ausführen lassen. Das ist eine ganz eindrucksvolle Sache, um zu sehen, wo den Menschen da Arbeit und Arbeitsplatz abgenommen wird.
Wer war das jetzt?
Das war Hans Berner. Der ist ITG-Lehrer. Der unterrichtet dieses Fach an der Schule.
Wo ist er? Der ist an der Breunbier-Oberschule in Langwitz.
Aber mit Internet hat das jetzt noch nicht so richtig...
Das hat nichts mit Internet zu tun, wie er schon sagte. Da geht es um diese Rundbedienung, Schreiben, Tippen, auch diesen Computer ein- und ausschalten. Das wird ja mittlerweile auch gelernt sein. Uns beschwert sich ja wieder Windows, dass es nicht ordentlich runtergefahren ist und so weiter. Solche Sachen lernt man dann.
Das ist ganz wichtig.
Du zeigst auf mich, was bedeutet das. Aber das habe ich doch schon gelesen. Übrigens gab es eben... Es hat tatsächlich niemand behauptet, das hätte Herzog nicht gesagt.
Was?
Nein, das hat Herzog nicht gesagt.
So intelligente Sachen sagt er nicht.
Aber ich finde es gut, also dem das so in den Mund zu legen.
Das gibt dem Ganzen gleich viel mehr Gewicht.
Genau. Brauchen die Schüler noch Lehrer? Ich glaube, wir müssen jetzt mal kurz unsere Konzeptpapiere sortieren. Deswegen schalten wir mal kurz auf die Musik um.
Naja, ich versuche seit etwa drei Minuten die Musik hoch zu ziehen. Das wäre nicht möglich, weil du immer noch was dazu sagst.
Bevor wir jetzt gleich hier das Fritz Kurz Info haben, wollen wir euch nochmal kurz aufs Thema Medienkompetenz zuführen, was auch immer das sein soll. Und so eine grobe Struktur, was Medienkompetenz sein soll, wäre sozusagen mal folgendes Modell. Medienkompetenz besteht aus drei Elementen. Einmal lesen, einmal schreiben und einmal kooperieren. Lesen heißt natürlich mediumspezifisch, irgendwie Daten von Informationen unterscheiden, vor allem aber auch Informationen verifizieren zu können, sie differenzieren zu können, sie differenziert wahrnehmen zu können, sozusagen all diese Eigenschaften, die man beim Fernsehen...
Finden ist auch eine ganz wichtige Komponente bei diesem Medium.
Ja, all diese Dinge. Willkommen dann... Es ist jetzt sozusagen erst mal grob fein, komme später noch zu. Das Element schreiben heißt natürlich, sich mediumspezifisch ausdrücken zu können, das heißt beispielsweise sich desbewusst zu sein, dass das, was man schreibt, eben nicht bewertet wird aufgrund der Gestik, des Tonpfahls, des Aussehens oder was auch immer, sondern einfach nur aufgrund Gottverdammter Buchstaben, die man über eine Klassatur mit Nüllen und Einzen und so weiter und so fort. Und kooperieren ist dann sozusagen die soziale Komponente, das heißt ja auch, dass man sich in Anbetracht des Kulturraums Internet, in dem man sich da bewegt oder des Kulturraums E-Mail oder was auch immer, eben ein bisschen auch den Empfindlichkeiten zum Beispiel desjenigen anpasst, mit dem man da redet, also ob man jetzt irgendwie mit Juden über den Holocaust redet oder mit irgendwie sonst was für Leuten, da gibt es dann immer noch so gewisse unterschiedliche. Oder du hattest da vorhin ein schönes Beispiel mit den Griechen.
Die Griechen, ja, man muss aufpassen, dass man nicht barfuß in Badehose in eine griechische Kirche reinmarschiert. Das ist so das Synonym für Medienkompetenz in der Kooperation im Internet, dass man nicht Leuten bewusst oder unbewusst auf den Schlips tritt.
Oder um es mit noch anderen Worten zu sagen.
Also der Begriff Medienkompetenz ist ja sehr schillernd und jeder versteht sicherlich ein bisschen was anderes darunter. Alle Schritte, die in diese Richtung weisen, sind sicherlich nützlich. Aber jeder hat einen anderen Zugang dazu. Das merken wir auch hier. Jeder hat auch eine andere Weise das aufzufassen, weil das ja eine abstrakte Materie ist, die unterschiedlich adaptiert wird. Also Medienkompetenz würde ich sehen, dass jemand nicht den Mut verliert, sich mit solchen Dingen auseinanderzusetzen, sondern auch ein Fahrkartenautomat erst mal untersucht, bevor er verzweifelt zum Schaffnerin.
Inzwischen haben wir auch mitgekriegt, dass der Live-Real-Audio-Stream tatsächlich unter www.fritz.de live.ram zu finden ist. Jop, mehr will ich gar nicht sagen. 22 Uhr, 118.
Machtgerangel, der jugoslawische Vizeregierungschef Draskovic ist entlassen worden. Als Grund wurden seine jüngsten Äußerungen genannt. Draskovic hatte Kritik am Kurs von Präsident Milošević geübt und die Stationierung einer internationalen Friedensgruppe im Kosovo befürwortet. Diplomatie, die Bemühungen um ein Ende des Krieges in Jugoslawien gehen weiter. UNO-Generalsekretär Anan traf am Abend in Moskau ein. Anan hatte zuvor mit Bundeskanzler Schröder gesprochen. Der russische Sonderbeauftragte Tschernomyrdin reist morgen nach Bonn, anschließend nach Rom und Belgrad. Aussage, das Flüchtlingshilfswerk der Vereinten Nationen hat von neuen Erschießungen im Kosovo berichtet. Flüchtlinge hätten erzählt, dass Männer im wehrfähigen Alter von serbischen Einheiten getötet würden. Aufschub. Die PLO hat darauf verzichtet, am 4. Mai einen unabhängigen Staat auszurufen. Grund sind die Wahlen in Israel Mitte Mai. Auftakt. Die türkische Staatsanwaltschaft hat ihre Klageschrift gegen PKK-Chef Öcalan eingereicht. In dem Prozess droht Öcalan die Todesstrafe wegen Landesverrats.
Wetter.
Nacht zunächst klar. Später bewölkt Temperaturen 9 bis 5 Grad. Morgen bewölkt im Tagesverlauf Heiter 13 bis 17 Grad.
Verkehr.
Berlin-Mitte, die Karl-Marx-Allee, ist zwischen Strausberger Platz und Grunastraße auf zwei Spuren eingeengt. Und A 115, Dreieck-Drehwitz Richtung Berlin und Gegenrichtung zwischen Samund und Potsdam-Babelsberg ist bis 2 Uhr früh. Wegen Brückenbauarbeiten in beiden Richtungen nur eine Spur befahrbar. Zudem kommt es zu kurzzeitigen Vollsperrungen.
Kurzzeitige Vollsperrungen, kurzzeitige Info mit Frau König-Meyer.
Kurzmeldungen.
Sexwerbung an bayerischen Schulen. In der Absprache mit dem bayerischen Kultusministerium hat die neue Mediengesellschaft Ulm allen Schulen im Freistaat das Magazin T-Online für Einsteiger, inklusive T-Online-Zugangssoftware, kostenlos zur Verfügung gestellt. Wir hoffen, dass wir ihren Schülern mit diesen Zideroms die Welt des Internets näherbringen, hieß es in einem Anschreiben an die Schulleiter. Der Landtagsabgeordnete Friedrich Ohnbacher, SPD, ließ bei der Durchsicht des Heftes auf gebilderte Sexfärbung. Dort unserieren unser Annahm die rasierte Telefonmaus Sieglinde A, Christine W blonde Haare, knackiger Po und Fiki L deren kostensichtige Angebote über T-Online-Abrüfer sind. In einem offenen Brief an die bayerische Kultusministerin Monika Holmeier fragte Ohnbach, ob diese Art der Vorbereitung auf das richtige Leben ein Beitrag zur Hightech-Offensive des bayerischen Ministerpräsidenten Edmund Stoiber sei. Das Kultusministerium hat mittlerweile alle Schulen aufgefordert, das Heft nicht zu verwenden.
Das Berliner Inline Festival. Das Skater-Ereignis für Profis und Mitmacher. Am 1. und 2. Mai auf dem Olympischen Platz. Das Berliner Inline Festival. Mit dem Fritz-Schnellskate-Staffellauf am 1. Mai. Das beste Team gewinnt drei brandneue Kickboards von K2. Moderiert von Radio Fritz Jan Weirau. Alle Infos bei der Hotline 030 302 1633. 030 302 1633. Das Berliner Inline Festival. Am 1. Mai ab 14 und am 2. Mai ab 39. Auf dem Olympischen Platz vor dem Olympiastadion.
I'm one of them in here, I'm one of them in here. Names like Nomumba, Kenyatta, Ilkuma, Hannibal, Atherton, Malcolm, Garvey, Haile Selassie. This poem is about apartheid, racism, fascism, the Ku Klakam clan, riots in Princeton, Atlanta, Jim Jones.
Den Mann wollten wir jetzt nicht unterbrechen. Jetzt müssen wir langsam wieder, denn es ist ja ein Blumen, genau gesagt der Computer Blumen bei Fritz jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat.
Chaos Radio heißt die Sendung und zwar deswegen, weil der Chaos Computer Club im Studio ist.
Außerdem das Analog Club DJ Team an den Plattenspielern. Tatsächlich alles analog, soweit ich mitgekriegt hab, alles von Venue.
Und schon wieder ein Mikrofon, der versucht, dem ganzen einen halbwegs noch irgendwie, ach da immer noch so ein bisschen was dazu zu sagen.
Einen moderaten Rahmen.
Einen moderaten Rahmen, ach schön, danke Andi.
Dem Ingenieur ist nicht zu schwör.
Steini, Anke, Frank und Andi sind im Studio und wir reden über...
Medienkompetenz.
Medienkompetenz, Computeranruhen. Wir wollen natürlich nachher auch mit euch reden, mit Schülern, mit Lehrern, mit Lehrerinnen, mit Schülern, mit Ex-Schülern. Ruf mal an, ey. Sollen wir jetzt schon anrufen? Ja, doch.
Wir wollen jetzt mal ohne machen.
Wir machen mal ohne.
Wir würden gerne eure Erfahrungen hören.
Und wissen, wie es ist an der Schule, weil wir euch nicht erzählen wollen, wie es bei euch ist, sondern ihr sollt erzählen, wie es bei euch ist.
Bei euch an der Schule. Und erzählt uns bitte nicht über Medienkompetenz, das ist etwas anderes.
Muss ab und zu mal sein. Ruft uns an unter der altbekannten Fritznummer und erzählt uns, was bei euch im Studio, im Studio, ah super, die sind völlig durch. Was bei euch in der Schule abgeht in Sachen Computer, in Sachen Medienkompetenz. Und das könnt ihr tun, nicht nur, wenn ihr Schüler seid, sondern natürlich auch, wenn ihr Lehrer oder Lehrerinnen seid.
Die Friss-Hotline ist geschaltet. 0331 für Posten, 7097, 110.
Wer ist denn da?
Hallo?
Hallo, wer bist du denn?
Ja, du klingst, also es liegt nicht an deiner Stimme, sondern eher an der Verbindung, du klingst saumäßig.
Ja, ich bin ein bisschen abgehackt heute irgendwie, weil ich gerade in der Bahn sitze, deswegen.
Ah ja, genau so klingt es.
Aber die Deutschen machen es beim Fahren so scheiße.
Dann versuchen wir mal, wie lange die Verbindung hält. Bist du Lehrer oder Schüler?
Ich bin weder Lehrer noch Schüler.
Ich bin auf der Schule schon raus.
Gut, was wolltest du denn zum Thema sagen?
Ja, eigentlich ruf ich an, weil ich wissen wollte, wie es bei Deutschland steht.
Ah ja, 5-5, unentschieden.
Unentschieden, ja? Ey, wunderbar.
Ey, was geht denn hier ab, ey? Will jetzt der Moderator euch vielleicht mal moderat irgendwie das Thema beibehalten?
Wie steht's denn?
Ey, ich will über Fußball nicht reden, ey.
Das Leben ist nicht so, dass man immer nur 4 zu 2, 2 zu 3.
Wer ist denn da?
Ja, wolltest du was zum Thema sagen?
Ja, ich bin selbst noch Schüler.
Und an unserer Schule sieht es, naja, eigentlich, es geht so aus.
Also wir haben ungefähr 15 Computer.
Für wie viele Schüler?
Für 400 ungefähr. Ja, und teilweise veraltet. Also die Hälfte ist irgendwie noch so auf dem Stand vom 486er ungefähr. Ja, und die anderen sind so einigermaßen okay so.
Und was macht der damit?
Ja, also wie gesagt der informationstechnische Grundkurs, wie das Teil da heißt erstmal. Und dann halt für die Oberstufen Informatik und mit C++ ein Programm halt schreiben.
Also nix Internet?
Nee leider nicht, das ist ja das Dumme.
Leider kein Internet.
Was würdet ihr gerne im Internet machen?
Ich denke, an der Schule ist ja klar mit anderen Schulen auf der ganzen Welt in Verbindung treten. Und halt was man im Internet macht.
Und haben eure Lehrer schon mal vom Internet in der Zeitung gelesen? Oder ist das irgendjemand ungesprochen?
Die wollen es eigentlich auch selber machen. Das ist das altbekannte Problem, dass kein Geld da ist. Wie es immer so schön heißt.
Die Lehrer sind eigentlich total dafür.
Mittlerweile ist es echt Boom, auch bei unseren Lehrern.
Was für Betriebssysteme habt ihr da?
95 und Ninox.
98 und Ninox ja.
Okay, an welcher Schule bist du? Das ist aber prinzipiell so, dass du sagst, es ist eigentlich okay, es gibt Ansätze.
Es gibt auf jeden Fall gute Ansätze, ja auf jeden Fall.
Okay, dann danke ich dir erst mal. Ist ja auch interessant, bei welchen Schulen sich das lohnt. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio, wer ist denn da? Hallo Ansgar.
Also ich bin ja Schüler und bei unserer Schule gibt es ungefähr, also wir haben einen Internetanschluss, einen Linux Apache Server und da sind, ich glaube, 45 Rechner angeschlossen, also das ist einiges. Und da sind auch 20 von Penn 533 und der Rest ist Celeron.
Und wir sind eigentlich fast nur, wir sind ziemlich viel im Internet, außer wenn die 40 Stunden verbraucht sind, die wir haben.
Aber wir programmieren zum Beispiel nicht, das ist mehr ein Topo Pascal. Aber ich würde lieber in C oder mal Pearl programmieren oder mal irgendwie was interessantes über das Internet lernen. CGD oder Java, aber nicht einfach nur surfen und nur irgendwie Suchmaschinen angucken.
Ansgar, in welcher Schule bist du?
Copernicus Oberschule in Berlin. Aber so direkt jetzt E-Mail pro Schüter oder so ist nicht drin? Doch, also wir haben als Betriebssystem Linux im Internet. Das heißt, jeder hat einen Login. Ja, und wir können auch E-Mails verschicken. Und das Teil heißt eigentlich auch E-Mail AG, aber da geht jeder nur ins Internet und surft rum. Und unser Englischlehrer hat mal veranstaltet so einen Austausch mit australischen Schülern. Aber es ist nicht so richtig in Gang gekommen. Also es funktioniert alles nicht so richtig. Das heißt, es gibt da jetzt auch kein direktes Angebot. Also irgendwie, so lerne ich sinnvoll, weis was, ich im Newsgroups mich umgucken oder so Geschichten? Also keine in dem Sinne Internetkurse oder so? Nee, wir haben nur gelernt, wie man sich in Suchmaschinen umguckt und hier F.R.Coolies. Und noch ein bisschen was übers Internet gelernt, also TCP-IP und so.
Aber das klingt doch jetzt schon mal sehr kompetent. Also zumindest habe ich den Eindruck, dass du wesentlich fundierter von diesen Sachen sprichst als sonst so mancher, den man kennt, bei dem an der Schule das nicht stattfindet. Hättest du den Eindruck, dass du was Besonderes an deiner Schule bist, dass du jetzt da der Computerfreak bist und die anderen haben da eher auch keine Ahnung, oder würdest du sagen, bei euch an der Schule ist das eher Standard, da wisst ihr alle so einigermaßen bestreit?
Nee, ich bin der Einzige. Also ich bin auch Webdesigner. Und in unserem Informatikkurs gibt es mich und noch jemand anders. Die schreiben fast nur eins in den Arbeiten und die anderen fangen ab drei bis sechs runter an.
Woran liegt das? Ist das Desinteresse? Oder ist das zu schwer?
Oder kann man das schlecht vermitteln?
Die Lehrer sind eigentlich ganz korrekt.
Aber die Schüler, als sie sich angeguckt haben, was da gelernt wird, haben sie es falsch verstanden.
Die haben gedacht, die lernen da eben Tabellenkalkulation und Fingersystem. Aber das haben wir da gar nicht gelernt. Deshalb ist irgendwann Desinteresse gekommen.
D.h. der Computer wird bei euch auch nur eingesetzt, um Informatik zu lernen und nicht eingesetzt, um mit diesem Medium andere Inhalte zu vermitteln?
Es läuft gerade an mit unserem Englischlehrer. Wir wollen den englischen Unterricht ins Internet verlagern. Aber ich habe da keine konkreten Sachen aus meinem Lehrer herausbekommen.
Also eher noch ein bisschen früh?
Klingt bisher gar nicht so schlecht. Mal gucken, was wir noch haben. Es kam gerade eine Frage aus dem Chat. Die kann man sich vielleicht mal merken. Dann können wir noch mal drauf eingehen, ob Medienkompetenz bedeutet, dass jemand lernt, wie er die Bravo z.B. richtig liest und von wem man sowas beigebracht kriegt.
Im Deutschunterricht. Oder im Sozial- PV-Unterricht.
Sexualkunde.
Im PV-Unterricht? Theoretisch. Mal gucken, vielleicht gibt es ja auch noch Leute, die uns sagen können, ob sie an der Schule lernen, wie man mit diesen gefundenen Informationen oder mit den Inhalten, die man aus dem Netz oder auch von anderen Quellen kriegt, dann in Anführungsstrichen richtig umgehen. Unsere Nummer ist immer noch geschaltet, 0331 für Potsdam, 70 97 110. Wer ist denn da?
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio.
Ich bin der Martin aus Wandsitz.
Also bei uns an der Schule sieht es ein bisschen anders aus, als bei denen, die eben da waren. Also wir haben auch ein Informatikkabinett mit 12 Rechnern. Und da ist nichts mit Internet surfen. Wir haben zwar alle eigene E-Mail-Adressen über GMXnet. Also können auch schreiben und senden und empfangen und so. Aber dann ist es doch mehr auf allgemeinen Bildung, so wie Tabellenkalkulation und wie nennt man das? Mit Schreiben und so ein Kram.
Textverarbeitung.
Ja genau, das ist das Wort zu mir.
Das ist manchmal, wenn man das Wort dann sucht, fällt es einem nicht ein. Und das Web-Surfen zählt jetzt zu dir, oder ich nenne es mal Web-Surfen, zählt jetzt nicht so zur allgemeinen Bildung oder der Umgang mit diesem World Wide Web, irgendwie Informationen beschaffene.
Also es wird nicht angeboten, dass man sich da jetzt als Kurs hinsetzt und dann rumsurft im Netz oder so. Wir hatten es heute als Sonderstunde mal für einen PB-Profilkurs. Da hatten wir so einen Chat mit Manfred Schäuble. Und dafür wird es ja mal genutzt oder so. Da kann man dann auch sich mal, wenn man Interesse hat, mal dazusetzen und angucken und so.
Da ist der PW-Lehrer auf der Mailing-Liste vom Bundestag und der Bundesregierung. Da ist der PW-Lehrer auf der Mailing-Liste vom Bundestag und der Bundesregierung. Der wird ihm das nämlich dann immer angeboten.
Also wir hatten es heute, das war einmalig, zum ersten Mal hatten wir das jetzt gemacht.
Warst du irgendwie sinnvoll mit dem zu chatten?
Hat er was gesagt, Herr Stolpe?
Also es waren einige Schulen aus dem Gas Brandenburg drinne. Und also pro Schule, dadurch das wir ein Kabinett sind, konnte bloß ein Computer mitreden. Und es lief nicht über einen Java-Server oder so, sondern irgendein billiger gemachter Chat. Und da ist man eben da rausgeflogen und so ein Kram und kommt dann überhaupt nicht mehr rein und konnte dann bloß noch zugucken, weil es außenseiter so.
Das heißt, der Stolpe hat den Medienkompetenztest nicht bestanden?
Naja doch, er hat schon die Leute, die dann von Anfang an mit drinne waren, da wurden die Fragen schon beantwortet und so.
Wie läuft denn so ein Chat eigentlich? Ist das dann ein moderierter Chat oder fragen alle drauf los?
Da sind die Fragen durch den Raum geballert und der hat dann gezielt immer auf einige geantwortet. Und dann war aber auch ein Moderator sozusagen und der hat dann gesagt, haltet euch mal ein bisschen zurück mit den Fragen und wir haben hier so viele zu lieben.
Hat da jemand schon mal was Anständiges gesehen? Weil es ist ja nicht so einfach zu handeln, wenn man jetzt sagt, 10 Brandenburger Schulen und Stolpe.
Mir liegt da eine kleine Information zu auf der Zunge, aber ich sage jetzt mal keinen Namen. Also zufällig ein Bekannter von mir, der hat das nämlich als Marktlücke entdeckt. Und zwar das Problem ist, es gibt Politiker und es gibt das Internet und es gibt irgendwie so etwas wie eine Assoziation. Assoziation bedeutet, wenn du irgendwie in der Zeitung liest, irgendwie Gerhard Schröder liest Zigarre, dann denkst du dir, hm stinkt und interessiert mich nicht. Wenn du aber liest, der chattet im Internet, dann denkst du, boah, der irgendwie ist in den neuen Medien und der kennt sich aus. Und der muss ja irgendwie toll sein. Und das heißt, was der macht, ist, der bietet diesen ganzen Stulle irgendwie alten Leuten, die vom Internet keine Ahnung kamen, diese Chats an, der nimmt da eine Unmenge für Kohle für. Und letztendlich heißt das dann, die sitzen daneben, daneben sitzt dann irgendwie einer, der die Tastatur bedient, da ist dann sozusagen ein Voice Interface geschaltet. Jajaja, das ist unglaublich. Und vor allem, was die dafür bezahlen. Also wie gesagt, ich will den jetzt nicht outen, und ich will hier niemand in die Pfanne hauen, aber ich hab mich da irgendwann mal bei einer Tasse Hirse-Tea mit ihm drüber unterhalten. Und also er verdient sich da nicht nur dumm und tusslig, sondern er amüsiert sich natürlich auch bei, weil die Leute wirklich... Ja, die haben natürlich teilweise wirklich das Problem irgendwie alleine des Verständnis zwischen Maustastatur und irgendwie dem, was sie gewohnt sind, irgendwie zu unterscheiden.
Das ist doch aber schön, das sagen doch alle, es wird so viel Geld im Internet verdient.
Das ist natürlich aber die Arbeitsplätze in der Informationsgesellschaft.
Ah nee, da wird es den richtigen aus der Tasche gezogen.
Martin, in welcher Schule bist du?
Am Gymnasium Antlitz. Und ich wollte noch was sagen, also ich bin jetzt in der 11.
Klasse, da geht es bei uns los mit Informatik.
Und in der 12. 13. wenn man es dann weiter als Kurz wählt, dann wird auch so programmiert und so. Ich weiß nicht mehr, was für Programme, aber da geht es dann doch schon richtig gezielter ab und so. Also jetzt ist es erstmal gemein.
Was mich noch interessiert, wenn du sagst Excel und solche Sachen, also Textverarbeitung, Tabellenkalkulation, kriegt man da nur beigebracht, wie die funktionieren und wie man die bedient oder auch wie man die verwendet, um seine private Buchführung zu machen, um irgendwie sein Leben auf eine Reihe zu kriegen.
Also wir haben es gemacht, Textverarbeitung mit Lebensläufen und so was, damit man es auf die Bewerbung anwenden kann. Und dann hatten wir Excel gemacht mit den ganzen Formeln, damit man mal so eine Mietstabelle machen kann oder einen Kilometer-Spiegel für ein Auto, wenn man dann was mehr verbraucht und wo man dann günstiger überweckt kommt mit den ganzen Formeln und so.
Also schon so praktische Anwendungen.
Und ja, da denken wir, da haben wir schon ganz kompetente Lehrer, die sich da ein bisschen hinterhängen und da ordentliche Sachen, die man heutzutage im Leben braucht, schon machen.
Koray, gibt es wirklich Leute im wirklichen Leben, die mit Excel-Tabellen den Treibstoffverbrauch ihres Autos irgendwie rumrechnen?
Ich weiß es nicht, aber ich denke mal, mit so einem Beispiel ist es besser, als wenn man irgendwelche trockenen Sachen macht.
Aber so direkt aus dem Leben gegriffen kommt mir der Schulung nicht vor. Das liegt vielleicht daran, dass ich irgendwie auch so ein stinkendes Ding fahre.
Ich würde die ganzen Schüler verdonnern, sämtliche Dinge, die sie kaufen, dafür Quittungen zu verlangen und die dann mit so einer Tabelle zu verwalten. Das brauchen sie später echt wirklich. Das geht mir jetzt voll auf den Keks. Habe ich nie gelernt. Ich dachte, du hast sie doch nicht.
Ich glaube, wenn man in der Schule einen BBL-Kurs gehabt hätte, hätte ich den nicht genommen.
Sorry, machen wir Musik. Das ist ja nicht BBL.
Danke, tschüss.
Erst mal ein Hörer verabschieden, dann die Musik kurz. Ihr könnt weiter anrufen und wir werden auch weiter mit euch reden, aber erstmal ein bisschen Entspannung. So, ich war gestern in der Bröndl-Überschule in Neukölln und da passiert was, naja vielleicht nicht einzigartig, aber auf jeden Fall seltenes in Berlin oder wenn nicht sogar in Deutschland, dass sich nämlich Lehrer nachmittags in ihrer Freizeit richtig selbst hinsetzen und unter Anleitung von einem Computer-Lehrer, diesem ETG-Lehrer, lernen, wie man grundsätzlich mit dem Computer umgeht. Nämlich das, was die Schülerinnen und Schüler sonst in der 8. Klasse lernen oder vielleicht auch schon zu Hause gelernt haben, nämlich wie schalte ich den Computer an, wie starte ich irgendwelche Programme, wie schreibe ich einen kleinen Text und wie mache ich den Computer wieder aus. Und so muss man sich zu vorstellen, dass da irgendwie 25 Lehrerinnen und Lehrer gesessen haben, die zum Teil wirklich das erste Mal vor dem Computer gesessen haben. Und ja, sie sind einfach hoch motiviert, das kann man nicht anders sagen. Aber ja, für euch, die vielleicht so ein bisschen Computererfahrung haben, mag das ganz witzig klingen, aber wir hören uns einfach mal an, wie das da gestern so zum Teil gelaufen ist.
Pack mich mal in den neuen Ort noch. Ich sag dir, das Ding macht mit uns, was es will.
Das war schon immer mein Riesen.
Also eins bringt die Kiste. Gut für Hypotoniker, gut für Niedrigblutdruckleute. Die kommen richtig in Fahrt, auch nach einem 12-Stunden-Tag. Wir hatten mal viel Spaß damit und haben mittlerweile E-Mails, Dateien und alles Mögliche gespeichert, aber irgendwie alles falsch gemacht. Hans, wie kommen wir auf den Anfang zurück? Wir sind irgendwo gelandet, aber der Start ist nicht mehr da.
Zieh mal runter die Maus.
Wie geht das denn?
Zieh.
Jetzt hab ich die Maus runtergezogen.
Ich bin gespannt ihr da mit zu sehen habt. Behört Chaos Radio mit dem Chaos Computer Club. Johnny am Restmikrofon sozusagen und mit euch an den Telefonen 0331 für Potsdam 7097110 ist unsere Nummer. Wir reden über das, was im Bereich Computer bei euch an der Schule gelehrt wird oder eben auch nicht. Und wir wollen ganz besonders gerne mal mit ein paar Lehrern oder Lehrerinnen reden. Wenn die also noch durchgehalten haben und uns zuhören, dann wäre das klasse, wenn ihr auch mal anruft. Denn ich denke, dass es bestimmt auch eine Menge Lehrer gibt, die sagen, ich würde gerne viel mehr machen, aber entweder ich habe selbst noch keine Ahnung oder wir haben das Material nicht oder so. Es wäre interessant, da auch mal die Probleme aus der Ecke zu hören. Wer ist denn da jetzt dran?
Ich bin auf einem Technik-OSZ, aber Sie haben auch einigermaßen neue Computer, aber die ist nur den höheren Klassenstufen zugänglich.
Was ist denn OSZ?
Ein OSZ, ein Oberstufenzentrum.
Ach so.
E-Technik 1 in Brandau, Berlin. Also diese besseren Rechner sind nur der Verwaltung zugänglich oder zum Beispiel der Mikroprozessor-Technik. Sowas haben wir da auch schon. Da programmieren die dann so 8086er oder so um. Jedenfalls, ja, was wir sozusagen benutzen dürfen, sind so 386er-Rechner mit Novel drauf und einen relativ paranoischen Systemadministrator.
Igitt?
Ja, also der ist so paranoid, dass er das System ziemlich zugemacht hat. Also man kann auch nicht immer sein Passwort ändern, wenn man überhaupt eins erst mal kriegt, weil das funktioniert auch nicht mehr so richtig.
Und wenn ihr diese Hürden überwunden habt, was dürft ihr denn da mitmachen? Also nix Internet oder?
Nein, auf den 36.8. schon ja nicht. Also ich habe gerüchteweise gehört, dass jetzt eine, also wir sind ja da mehrere unterschiedliche Klassenstufen sozusagen und auch hier so Auszubildende sind da und dass eine Gruppe dort jetzt gerüchteweise einen Internetzugang hat über 64K ISDN.
Aber woran liegt es denn so, dass ihr da irgendwie nicht rankommt oder dass es einfach auch keine anderen Geräte sind?
Na, ich würde einfach mal sagen, die Leute sind erstmal nicht gerade kompetent. Also die finden Internet zwar ganz toll, die Lehrer alle und was man da so schön als alles machen kann, aber so selber haben sie eigentlich erstmal keine Ahnung. Und ja, und dafür dürfen wir dann in Informatik mit Pascal programmieren und so ein tolles Nicky- und Carrel-System. Das sind so Roboter und die darf man dann da so über ein 15 mal 15 Spielfeld jagen und irgendwelche Kugeln hin und her tragen.
Oh Mann, ja, ja, das kenn ich.
Ja, das haben sie meinerzeit auch schon gemacht.
Das ist jetzt 15 Jahre her.
Aber da gab es noch kein Internet.
Martin, ich danke dir erstmal. So, das ist also vom Oberstufenzentrum.
Was hat der gesagt?
Spannau, genau. Ich hab schon jemand aufgegeben. Auch aufgegeben. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio.
Hallo, Malte.
Ich wollte mich auch mal zum Thema Schulen und Internet melden. Und zwar bei uns sieht das so aus, wir sollten jetzt neu Internetzugang kriegen, haben für Informatik, Rechner, mit 120 Megabyte, 16 Megabyte RAM. Da wurde natürlich erstmal ein Internet Explorer 4.0 drauf installiert, unter anderem auf 95. Dementsprechend langsam sind die natürlich geworden. Dann hat uns, hat irgendeine Firma gesagt, man müsste unbedingt von Elsa ein Internetrouter nehmen, mit drei ESD-Imports, wovon höchstens einer genutzt wird. Denn alles wurde natürlich über BNC angeschlossen, also Twisted Peer Netzwerk oder sowas ist nicht. Und dann haben sie wohl nochmal extra Geld kassiert, dafür, dass sie TCP-IP-Protokoll auf den Rechner installiert haben.
Extra hart.
Ein Kumpel von mir hat vorhin gesagt, dass man da eine Linux-Kiste einfach hinstellt mit Gateway-Funktion. Das kann ja kein Mensch administrieren, sowas kommt für uns überhaupt nicht in Frage. Die Firma hat das bei uns alles bisher gemacht.
Die Frage stellt sich wirklich, wenn man so was hört, ob es nicht in diesem Fall wirklich langsam so weit ist, dass man sich irgendwie die drei, vier Schüler aus der Schule nimmt, die sich damit richtig auskennen, den vielleicht noch irgendwie für zwei Monate einen Linux-Administrator zur Seite stellt, damit dann kein Unfug getrieben wird, und dann ist das wahrscheinlich alles kostengünstiger und vor allen Dingen lehrreicher, als wenn man da irgendwie eine Firma ranlässt, die für jede Installation des Start-Buttons...
Ja, schon richtig. Vor allem, wir sind hier drei Leute in einer Schule, die sich auch recht viel mit Linux beschäftigen. Wir haben auch zu Hause unser Netzwerk, haben wir mit Gateway und so am Internet dran, immer mit Dial-In-Verbindungen. Also praktisch das, was die auch bräuchten, haben wir denen auch gesagt und so, dass wir das hinkriegen würden, aber ist nicht.
Das heißt, die Lehrer haben Angst, euch da ranzulassen, oder?
Ja, die denken einfach, dass können nur vernünftige Firmen machen, die auch einen gewissen Ruf haben.
Ja, also mal ganz ehrlich, ich würde, wenn ich Schulleiter wäre, auch nicht unbedingt jetzt ein Schüler des gesamten Linux-Systems...
Ja, aber so ist das, Johnny.
Ich meine, wer soll das denn machen?
Es muss auf jeden Fall, es können ja die Schüler machen, trotzdem brauchst du jemanden dabei, der vielleicht genauer Bescheid weiß, was dann nachher passiert ist.
Bloß da landest du ganz schnell bei so Kompetenzsimulationsanstalten, die dann viel Geld dafür nehmen, die dir da Bullshit hinsicheln.
Das musst du natürlich selber ausfiltern können.
Ja, aber wie soll das ein Schulleiter machen? Ja, da braucht man dann Hilfe.
Ja, man muss es nochmal so sehen, die haben ja gute 1000 Mark für diesen Elza-Dings ausgegeben, für diesen Internetanschluss. Und im Endeffekt, ein alter 416er mit Linux, der hätte niemals 1000 Mark gekostet. Da hätten sie eher noch einen Lehrer zwei Tage auf den Windows-Lehrgang schicken können, dass der sogar ITG unterrichten kann. Richtig oder so. Es bringt eigentlich nichts, man kriegt Ärger, wenn man irgendwie, was ich den Beispiel in letzter Zeit war, einen Kumpel von mir, der gerade ITG hat, so haben beigebracht gekriegt, wie man Bildschirmschoner unter Windows einstellt. Von wegen auf Startbutton klicken, Einstellungen, Systemstörungen, Anzeige. Jemand hat das nicht verstanden, fragt einen Kumpel von mir, der sagt, ja, klick mit der rechten Maustaste auf dem Hintergrund und dann kommt der Eigenschaften und da einfach aufklicken. Die Lehrerin sieht das, fängt an zu meckern. Meinem Unterricht wird das aber anders gemacht. Wir halten die HW, wie ich das gewohnt bin, und hat gleich Anschiss gekriegt.
Also die sind nicht nur blöd, sondern auch ignorant.
Ja, irgendwie schon.
Das finde ich, das finde ich nicht, so schwarz-weiß zu malen.
Ja, Johnny, aber jetzt lass uns doch auch mal tacheles reden. Sollen wir jetzt sagen, das ist eine suboptimale Form des Informationstechnischen?
Nein, es ist aber immer kompletter Quatsch, sich hinzustellen und zu sagen, die sind blöd und ignorant. Also ich hab dann, wir haben ganz kurz. Es hat mit blöd und ignorant nichts zu tun, sondern du stehst einfach einem Phänomen gegenüber, was es in der Form noch nicht gab. Das Problem ist ein ganz anderes, dass es nämlich einen Wissensvorsprung gibt inzwischen bei Schülern. Das hat aber nichts damit zu tun, dass ein Lehrer, der sich mit dem Medium bisher nicht auseinandergesetzt hat, weil er vielleicht auch einen Job hat, vielleicht nicht so ist, als der zu kauft, dass der blöd ist.
Ja, aber Johnny, mit ignorant meine ich, die Unfähigkeit eines Lehrers auch mal zuzulassen, dass er vom Schüler was beigebracht bekommt. Darüber können wir ja reden. Ja, aber das ist Gottverdammt ignorant. Und welchen Begriff soll ich das denn belegen?
Das ist etwa so ignorant, wie es bestimmte Sachen gibt, mit denen du dich im Bereich Radio zum Beispiel nicht auseinandersetzen willst, weil du keinen Bock drauf hast.
Ja, aber Andi würde die dann ignorant. Andi würde aber dann nicht versuchen, die jemand anderen beizubringen.
Doch. Also da hab ich aber schon was.
Dann aber auf die Ohren. Ich mein, Andi ist auch manchmal ignorant.
Also ich mein, verstehst du das, wie ich blöd und ignorant ist? Dann schaffst du sofort zwei Fronten und dann kommst du überhaupt nicht weiter.
Okay, man kann das auch diplomatischer formulieren. Es ist offenbar so, dass Lehrer damit überfordert sind, dass sie hier in einen Wissensbereich vorstoßen, wo ihre Rezipienten ihnen eigentlich was beibringen könnten. Und nicht sie ihren Rezipienten. Und aufgrund dieser Überforderung benehmen sie sich mitunter suboptimal und lassen den ihnen angebotenen Lernoptionen nicht den Fluss, den sie ihnen lassen können. Ist das jetzt netter ausgedrückt, Johnny? Ja gut, aber es war irgendwie, du hast gesagt, ich will nicht sagen, die sind ignorant, aber ich will sagen, es kommt halt mitunter vor, dass Schüler sehr wohl die Möglichkeit auch anbieten, hey, ich könnte dir das erklären, lieber Lehrer. Und die Lehrer, die sagen, na nee, das Spiel funktioniert hier aber andersrum. Ich bin der Lehrer und du bist der Schüler.
Ich glaube, das ist genau das Problem, dass wir eine Situation haben, die irgendwie einfach nicht zugelassen wird. Also ich glaube, das ist da der gesamte Ansatz der Schutzverletzung. Ich habe gestern auch nochmal darum gefragt und jemanden gefunden, der diese Ignoranztheorie absolut widerlegen kann. Da haben wir nämlich die Marianne Birke-Braun, die hat nämlich gestern auch nochmal was dazu gesagt.
Ich habe eine Mischung aus Frust und Wut, wenn ich mit den Schülern spreche, weil ich mich langsam schäme, dass meine Schüler in einer Sprache sprechen, die ich nicht mehr verstehe. Und da ich diesen Zustand für mich nicht akzeptieren will, den ich nicht gerne habe, sitze ich jetzt hier und schwitze und bin eigentlich ganz unglücklich, dass ich immer noch nicht alles verstanden habe.
So viel, das ist natürlich oft auch Unsicherheit oder keine Ahnung, dass man das vielleicht in so einem Schema hat.
Die Frage ist, ob man sich Unsicherheit eingestehen will oder ob man die überdecken will mit Ich habe hier aber die Herrschaft.
Also ich will nicht alle Leute decken, die ihre Unsicherheit nicht zugeben können. Aber um die Sache mit dem ITG Unterricht, was eben aufkam, noch mal zu klären, um das Lehren zu dürfen, muss ich ein Jahr lang einmal die Woche an die Uni gehen als Lehrerin. Das heißt, wenn ich das ja noch von vorher nicht mitgebracht habe, diese Fakultas, muss ich sie mir auch erst an der Uni erwerben.
Und was machst du da an der Uni?
Also ich weiß es noch nicht, ich werde es nächstes Jahr machen. Aber grundsätzlich nehme ich an, dass es wieder mal um Einführungen in was ist ein PC, was kann er, was ist das Internet und ähnliches geht. Und wenig darum, wie ich es präsentiere, sondern wahrscheinlich leider wieder darum, dass ich rezipiere und mir dann hinterher überlege, wie kann ich es den Schülern nur so beibringen, dass es nicht so langweilig ist, wie es bei mir war.
Ja, ich wollte noch sagen, es gibt ja auch bei uns ein, zwei Lehrer, die lassen sich was bei. Und was ich besonders zu Lobenswert finde, ist, wir haben auch in der Chemie jetzt Rechner im Einsatz mit AD-Wandlern. Und da stehen die Lehrer voll dahinter, die wollen sich das beibringen lassen und die wollen es auch verstehen. Aber wie gesagt, das ist Chemie, wo sie es eingebracht haben wollen. In ETG eigentlich weniger.
Das heißt, es gibt aber schon irgendwie Hoffnungsschimmer.
Es gibt Hoffnung auf jeden Fall, ja.
Das ist schön.
Wir müssen unbedingt mal mit Lehrern sprechen, ne?
Ja, eigentlich ja. Ich will da vielleicht auch nochmal berichten aus meiner Schulzeit. Die ist ja nun doch auch noch nicht ganz so lange her. Ich habe eigentlich gelernt, dass es gut funktioniert mit Lehrern, die ein Vertrauensverhältnis zu ihren Schülern akzeptieren. Und ganz schlecht läuft bei Lehrern, die glauben, sie müssten ihre Schüler im Griff haben. Oder die, die da einfach Angst haben, dass es drunter und drüber geht und nicht Mut für neue Sachen haben. Also meinen Physiklehrer beispielsweise, mit dem habe ich mich privat getroffen, weil der von mir wissen wollte, wie das mit dem Atari läuft. Der hat sich einen gekauft, weil ich einen hatte. Und dem habe ich das dann beigebracht. Und das war völlig in Ordnung. Daraus entwickelt sich auch ein durchaus freundschaftliches Verhältnis zwischen Schülern und Lehrern. Und dabei kann ich als Schüler, damals konnte ich auch viel besser akzeptieren und viel besser verstehen, was er mir beibringen wollte. Das war nun mal sein Job, wir mussten die Zeit gemeinsam verbringen. Aber ich habe das auch viel besser selber als Schüler annehmen können. Es ist nämlich nicht so, dass nur die Lehrer nicht akzeptieren, was die Schüler bringen, sondern die Schüler genauso nicht akzeptieren, was die Lehrer bringen. Und dass da einfach eine Diskrepanz, eine Schlucht existiert zwischen diesen beiden Welten. Die einen müssen das, weil die verdienen auch einfach nur ihr Geld damit. Und die anderen müssen das, weil das ist Gesetz, dass sie da hin müssen. Wenn man sich da nicht arrangiert, dann knallt es. Und zwar auf beiden Seiten. Deswegen sind meistens die Schüler genauso ignorant und blöd wie die Lehrer. Und meistens auch selber Schulden an ganz vielen Stellen.
Telefonieren wir noch ein bisschen und hören vielleicht, ob wir da noch ein bisschen mehr dahinter kommen, woran es liegt. Und wir brauchen unbedingt Lehrer bzw. Lehrerinnen. Den haben wir jetzt hier. Offensichtlich kein Lehrer.
Ja, stimmt. Allerdings. Da hat vorhin jemand angerufen vom OSZ Elektrotechnik. Da habe ich auch mein Abi gemacht. Der Junge, der hat schon ziemlich recht. Also da sind schon ein paar Lehrer dabei, die auch ins Internet wollen. Also ein Schneekschnack. Bloß dieser, man nennt ihn Systemadministrator oder wie auch immer. Der hat da sein dickes Novellnetzwerk aufgebaut und kriegt da die tieresten Probleme und will eigentlich überhaupt nicht, dass irgendein Schüler da irgendwas macht. Also E-Mail-Adressen, er selber hat einen natürlich, aber Schüler oder so, dem wird es nicht so beigebracht, was das ist und was weiß ich was.
Ist dieser Systemadministrator da Lehrer oder hat er tatsächlich nur einen Job als Systemadministrator?
Ne, der ist unter anderem auch Lehrer.
Und da ist er genauso widerlich oder?
Ja, also er ist schon ziemlich heavy, so grundsätzlich. Ich hatte Informatik auch als Prüfungsfach und naja.
Er hat doch seinen Abi.
Ja, ja, klar.
Können sie dir nicht mehr aberkennen, du darfst jetzt frei reden.
Ja, ja, stimmt, das darf ich jetzt. Und ja, unter anderem, der ist so... Seine Adresse ist... Ich weiß auch nicht, also anstatt dass ich irgendwas, ja, keine Ahnung, Linux zum Beispiel wäre eine echte Alternative da in diesem ganzen Haus, weil er hat da sein Novell-Netzwerk halt aufgebaut und neuerdings jetzt auch erarbeitet er mit TCP-IP. Ja, jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, warum er nicht ins Internet kommt, wenn sein lokales Netz mit 192, 186, 1, noch was anfängt. Ja, das ist eigentlich egal. Und selber, ja, weiß ich auch nicht, ist ja ziemlich, ja doch. Also ich hatte vorhin irgendwas von Ignoranz und sowas und von wegen Wissensvorsprung, den die Schüler haben. Und ja, würde ich genauso sehen. Und ich weiß nicht, vielleicht hat er auch einfach bloß Schiss. Das kann natürlich auch sein. Der hat da jetzt, also, ja, der hat da jetzt ein Modem, jetzt neuerdings ein Modem, 14, 4 oder 28er oder was immer das ist. Na ist auch egal. Das lässt er per Zeituhr steuern, damit er halt keiner da Blödsinn machen kann. Ne, das hat er halt in der Nacht angeschaltet.
Ich hab ein Novell-Netzwerk noch nie benutzt. Das braucht man da ewig zu, bis man damit klarkommt.
Das ist im Grunde genommen ein Novell-File-Sharing unter Daß. Also das hat nichts mit einer Vernetzung, wie wir sie jetzt heute auf DCP-IP-Basis. Naja, es gibt da auch Dienste wie E-Mail, aber eben lokal. Und das ist völlig ein Unsinn.
Naja, Novell ist eher die Netzwerk eben unten runter. Du kannst darauf auch Services aufsetzen. Aber Novell ist eigentlich hoffnungslos veraltet.
Ich meine, ich weiß aber nicht, man kennt das ja auch aus Banken und anderen Behörden, wo irgendwann mal das Riesenpaket an den Konzernen verkauft worden ist für, weiß ich wie viele Milliarden. Und das muss jetzt die nächsten 30 Jahre benutzt werden, weil da sind auch die Support-Verträge abgeschlossen.
Nee, die meisten Leute kaufen Novell, weil die als Handbücher wirklich sehr schöne rote Ringbuchordner haben, die sich hervorragend auf schwarzen Regalen machen. Also das sieht unglaublich kompetent aus.
Nein, du kennst es einfach gut, wenn sich vielleicht 30 Arbeitsplätze einen Drucker teilen wollen und wenn vielleicht noch mal der Chef der Sekretärin eine Mail schreiben will. Denn denk ich es.
Naja, aber benutzen willst du das nicht wirklich? Das lässt sich alles billiger, einfacher, schneller und schöner mit Linux realisieren beispielsweise.
Naja klar, vor allem, dass es auch überhaupt, also ich finde, gerade wenn er so ein Lehrer ist und Vorkenntnisse hat, dann dürfte es für ihn eigentlich auch kein Problem sein, sich in sowas wie Linux zum Beispiel einzuarbeiten. Ich weiß nicht genau, ob er sich das nur nicht traut oder ob, ja ich weiß es auch nicht. Also jedenfalls weiß ich, dass da ein Haufen ziemlich fähiger Schüler auf diesem Gymnasium ist.
Aber gibt es denn da eigentlich keine Gesprächsebene, wo zum Beispiel, die Frage ist ja auch, wer legt denn in so einer Schule eigentlich fest, was da installiert wird? Das ist er. Das ist er und nur er.
Es gibt ziemlich viele Lehrer, die auch noch Informatik lernen, aber die haben halt auch nicht viel zu sagen. Die hätten auch gerne ihre eigene E-Mail-Adresse über die Schule oder sowas, aber ich glaube, das haben die nicht. Und jetzt neu, da hat der eine der Freunde dran, gesagt, dass die einen ISTN-Anschluss bekommen sollten. Keine Ahnung, ob. Also ich kann mir eigentlich ehrlich gesagt nicht vorstellen, dass da schon irgendwas passiert ist und dass es irgendwie so eine Gruppe gibt, die sich da mit irgendwas, keine Ahnung, was auch immer, RTML-Programmierung oder keine Ahnung was beschäftigt. Also ich glaube es einfach mal nicht. Ja, ist eigentlich ein bisschen schade, gerade weil dieses ganze Gebäude heißt ja OSZ für Elektrotechnik. Und naja, dass da so relativ wenig passiert ist, naja, ist irgendwie schade.
Ich hab mal, aber ich kann dich trösten, es ist dann später, wenn du aus solchen Schulen rauskommst, und du, zum Beispiel, ich hab mal versucht, an einer Fachhochschule Nachrichtentechnik zu studieren. Und es war dort nicht denkbar, Nachrichtentechnik zu benutzen. Also ich bin da irgendwie, da passieren ja dann später noch ganz andere Dinge. Also lass dich von solchen Namen bloß nicht irre leiden.
Naja, aber was ich weiß zum Beispiel ist, das OSZ-Nachrichtentechnik an der Osloer Straße. Vielleicht könnte da nachher auch noch mal jemand anrufen. Der da mal kurz war, da ist das zum Beispiel eine völlig andere Situation. Die sind da intern recht gut verkabelt, lassen ganz gute Schüler auch mal am Surfer sitzen oder sowas und fahren meiner Meinung auch Linux oder sogar Unix, System 5, keine Ahnung.
Ich finde es immer schön, wenn es so technisch wird, dann so ach es ist egal.
Ich finde das gut.
Ich finde das auch gut.
Ich finde das nicht gut.
Ja, stein dir denn nicht.
Du bist in der Mennaheit heute.
Boris, ich sag dir trotzdem schon mal Tschüss und vielen Dank. Vielleicht ruft nachher noch jemand an vom Oberstufzentrum Osloer Straße. Und jetzt wollen wir wirklich mit einem Lehrer oder einer Lehrerin sprechen. Alle, die jetzt keine Lehrer sind, schmeiß ich raus. Ihr müsst dann nochmal anrufen.
Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Hallo.
Hartmut, bist du Lehrer?
Ich bin kein Lehrer, aber insofern, dass ich mehrere Lehrer schon PC gekauft habe, privat bzw. versucht habe, ihnen etwas beizubringen.
Was machst du denn?
Ich bin jetzt IT-Berater, also für SAP Bahn. Also in ganz anderen Bereichen.
Aber du hast mit Lehrern zu tun, da kommen wir schon mal sehr näher.
Ja, das kam daher auch. Meine Freundin ist Lehrerin im Gymnasium. Aber in Deutsch Musik. Das sind gerade diese Geisteswissenschaftler, das ist ganz extrem. Die wollen alle mit dem PC gar nicht arbeiten. Alleine haben sie Kurse besucht, denn extra, weil es auch höchstens heißt, wenn ich in Kontakt habe mit Frauen, die dann Frauenkurse besucht haben, weil sie das von mir dann überhaupt nicht gecheckt haben. Irgendwo bin ich da auch zu ungeduldig. Das fing einfach nur ganz normal, Word, Briefe zu schreiben. Und die haben einfach keine Geduld. Ja, warum geht denn das nicht? So ungefähr das, was vor in diesen Mitschnitten war. Genau so läuft es ab. Nach einem halben Jahr rufen sie mich an, wie kann ich das auf die Kette speichern?
Wie alt sind die so?
Ja, die sind alle jenseits der 40.
Und noch mal eine Frage. Hast du schon anderen Leuten auch sowas beigebracht? Also Nicht-Lehrern? Kannst du da vergleichen?
Mach mal. Und zwar, ich komme aus dem technischen Bereich, wo ich auch teilweise Schulungen sowohl Maschinensteuerung als auch IT-Beratung, also SHP-Bahn, so Key-User. Und das ist natürlich etwas ganz anderes, diese Key-User in einem Programm einzuführen. Weil die haben ja ganz andere Vorkenntnisse. Die haben vorher schon Jahre gearbeitet. Und diejenigen zum Beispiel, ich habe das bei Maschinensteuerung gelernt, oder wenn ein Computer in der Fertigung eingeführt wird, die vorher, also im technischen Bereich dann, die vorher nie damit gearbeitet haben, die sind sehr sehr ängstlich, aber die sind wissbegierig. Da ist der Wille da. Und bei den anderen, da vermisse ich eigentlich einfach diesen Wiss.
Würdest du sagen, dass es wichtiger ist, oder würdest du einschätzen, dass es wichtiger wäre, in den Schulen den Umgang mit konkret bestimmten Programmen, Programmversionen, Word, Excel, was auch immer zu lehren? Oder ob es wichtiger ist, den grundsätzlichen Umgang und das grundsätzliche Verständnis eines Computers, also dieses Instruments, zu vermitteln und dann hinterher möglicherweise sich von Leuten wie dir das etwas einfacher beibringen lassen zu können? Was glaubst du, ist da sinnvoller?
Also ich hab das bei meiner Tochter, die war jetzt im Schüleraustausch in den USA und sie wollte auch, E-Mail, brauche ich deine E-Mail, das brauche ich alles gar nicht. Wir waren noch nicht mal einen Tag drüben, hat sie mich gleich angerufen, wie meine E-Mail-Adresse ist. Die hatten ganz anderen Kontakt gehabt, das ist ganz normal. Das hat jeder auch zu Hause irgendwo mit E-Mail und so weiter. Da kommen jetzt auch permanent immer E-Mails an. Und sie hatten Zugang bekommen, die haben sofort auch zehn Finger blind gelernt. Wunderbar, alles in der elften Klasse. Das heißt, das ist ganz normale Voraussetzung. Und sie macht das jetzt auch hier. Sie ist weiter als ihr Lehrer. Sie schreibt ganz normal ihre Hausaufgaben. Teilweise darf das nicht. Aber teilweise schreibt sie das ganz normal im PC. Und sie hat keine Probleme mit Lehrern. Das fängt ganz einfach an, wenn die z.B. auch in Word, mit manchen Formatvorlagen oder selbst mit Tapulatoren arbeiten. Nein, die arbeiten nur einfach immer mit dieser Space-Taste, also mit der Leertaste. Und dann sind wir immer weiter. Und dann begreifen wir einfach nicht. Ja gut, das ist dann immer irgendwie nicht richtig funktioniert mit den Abständen, das sieht unsauberbar aus. Und ich sag das einfach, der will ja nicht da. Und wenn ich nicht will, das ist so wie Leute, die gegen Anti-Audi eingeschaltet sind, die wären nie gute Autofahrer.
Aber kann ich das tatsächlich dann so zusammenfassen, das wäre eine ziemlich, wie soll ich sagen, deutliche Hypothese, würdest du tatsächlich sagen, dass das, was Lehrer von anderen unterscheidet, ist die Nichtbereitschaft, selbst zu lernen?
Das ist natürlich ein extremes Problem.
Ja, aber vielleicht ist da ja was dran.
Da ist garantiert natürlich so ein Kompetenzproblem, dass man irgendwie Lehrer ist und plötzlich denkt, wie und ich soll jetzt nochmal selber was lernen?
Nö. Du meinst, das lebenslange Lernen scheitert an den Lehrern?
Unter Umständen vielleicht. Das ist eine interessante These.
Wir sollten das nicht pauschalieren, aber...
Nein, aber es ist schon interessant.
Ja, es ist schon was dahinter.
Vor allem...
Ich war vor nicht allzu langer Zeit immer auf so einem Vortrag vom Personalvorstand, vom BMW. Und der hat auch gesagt, da ging es aber auch um Realschüler und so weiter, die nur ganz normale Lehre machen, allgemein um die Jugend. Und da sagt er auch, was er einfach vermisst, oder auch selbst bei Studenten, das ist einfach, dass sie sich selbst auch etwas beibringen können und selbst erarbeiten. Also Vorgaben bekommen und dann im Team arbeiten. Weil tatsächlich auch bei den Lehrern, ich kenne es gerade bei denen, mit denen ich auch Kontakt habe, da gehen die Computermusik überhaupt nicht, sie gehen einfach vor und das muss ich machen. Entweder schreibe ich eine 1 oder eine 6. Und das ist einfach so, dass dieses selbst der Arbeiten, auch mal Freiräume, wo das Schüler Ziele bestimmen können, das gibt es einfach gar nicht. Ich mache auch mal ein bisschen Internet und so weiter. Und die wollen alles genau vorgegeben haben. Genauso wie die, denen man mitgenommen hat, Internet surfen. Die muss man ja überall suchen. Die erwarten ungefähr, ich bekomme ein Buch serviert, schlage einfach auf, innerhalb verzeichne ich das Cookie-Fond und schon habe ich das Ergebnis im Internet. Solche Vorstellungen geistern, dann sind sie wahnsinnig enttäuscht und kommen nie wieder.
Die Eier kauen im Vollmilch.
Wir werden mal gucken, dass wir trotzdem noch Lehrer und Lehrerinnen rankriegen. Ich danke dir schon mal, ja? Ich habe gerade im Chat jemand erzählt, wer war es? Kane hat erzählt, eine Heinrich-Böll-Gesamtschule in Bochum, Nordrhein-Westfalen, da gab es eine Schülerinitiative und dort hat man sich jetzt scheinbar darauf geeinigt, dass es einen Internetzugang für alle Schüler der Schule geben soll, für 15 Mark im Monat plus Telefongebühren, also man muss da selber etwas mittragen. Und die Admins in diesem System dann sind tatsächlich Schüler. Also da wird dann Verantwortung auf die Schüler auch übergeben. Wir haben gleich einen Fritz-Kurz-Info, dann werden wir weiter telefonieren und wir bitten nochmal alle Lehrer und Lehrerinnen anzurufen und von euren Erfahrungen zu berichten. Denn das geht wirklich nicht darum, dass man jetzt hier irgendwelche Schuldigen sucht, sondern einfach, es wäre interessant mal zu hören, wie das aus der Sicht derjenigen ist, die ja schließlich vor diesem Problem noch mehr stehen als die Schüler. Die Schüler können nach Hause gehen, schmeißen ihren eigenen PC an und lernen den Kram eben selber. Learning by doing, wie man so schön sagt.
Ja, aber Johnny, die Schuldigen interessiert mich ja auch.
Ja, aber die müssen wir woanders suchen, nicht bei den Lehrern, nicht bei den Schülern.
Ich suche bei sowas nicht wirklich Schuldige. Nö, weil, ich versuche einfach...
Die Struktur ist ein Problem. Aber da reden wir nachher über die Struktur und was man tun kann und wie, und was da reden wir einfach nachher nochmal ein bisschen drüber.
Was man tun kann, darüber sollten wir uns wirklich Gedanken machen. Ja, haben wir ja auch schon. Also ich bin vorbereitet.
Mach mal Lala, ey.
Heißt es ja nicht umsonst Chaosradio, ne?
Wenn Fritz im Raum Angermünde, dann 100, 1.
23 Uhr, 33.
Luftalarm. In mehreren Städten Jugoslawiens mussten die Bewohner am Abend erneut die Luftschutzkeller aufsuchen. Die Sirenen erzönten in Belgrad sowie in Nis, Novizat und Kragujevac. Auch in der Gegend um die Kleinstadt Zudulica soll es einen neuen Angriff gegeben haben. Dort war gestern eine NATO-Bombe in ein Wohngebiet eingeschlagen. Etwa 20 Menschen kamen dabei ums Leben.
Machtgerangel.
Wegen seiner umstrippenden Äußerungen ist der jugoslawische Vizeministerpräsident Dražković entlassen worden. Dražković hatte in scharfer Form die sozialistische Partei von Präsident Milošević kritisiert. Diplomatie. Die Bemühungen um ein Ende des Krieges in Jugoslawien gehen weiter. UNO-Generalsekretär Anan traf am Abend in Moskau ein. Anan hatte zuvor mit Bundeskanzler Schröder gesprochen. Der russische Sonderbeauftragte Cernumürdin wird morgen in Deutschland und Italien erwartet. Aufschub. Die PLU hat darauf verzichtet, am 4. Mai einen unabhängigen Staat auszurufen. Grund sind die Wahlen in Israel Mitte Mai. Auftakt. Die türkische Staatsanwaltschaft hat ihre Klageschrift gegen PKK-Chef Öcalan eingereicht. In dem Prozess droht Öcalan die Todesstrafe wegen Landesverrats. Fußball. Deutschland hat das Länderspiel gegen Schottland 0 zu 1 verloren.
Wetter.
Nacht zunächst klar, später bewölkt, Temperaturen 9 bis 5 Grad. Morgen bewölkt, im Tagesverlauf heiter 13 bis 17 Grad.
Verkehr.
A115 Dreieckdrehwitz Richtung Berlin und Gegenrichtung. Zwischen Sammund und Potsdam-Babelsberg ist bis 2 Uhr früh wegen Brückenbauarbeiten in beiden Richtungen nur eine Spur befahrbar. Zudem kommt es zu kurzzeitigen Vollsperrungen.
Ein Fritz-Kurzinfo mit Frau König-Meyer.
Fritz präsentiert Fusion House mit den DJ und Hausproduzenten Ian Pooley. Ian Pooley, Pierre, Dax und Wimpy legen auf Fusion House. Freitag, 30. Präsentiert von Fritz.
Die wunderbare Musik, die ihr hört, wird aufgelegt vom Analog-Club-DJ-Team. Ihr hört das Chaos Radio. Zu Gast im Studio sind Steini, Anke, Frank und Andi vom CCC.
Johnny, der Mikrofon.
Und das Thema ist im Moment noch ziemlich auf Computer an Schulen beschränkt, im weitesten Sinne, aber geht es um das Wort, was ich schon wieder vergessen hab.
Medienkompetenz, was so viel heißt, wie Kompetenz mit Medienumgang.
Mit Medien.
Und da haben wir auf jeden Fall definitiv das Problem, dass es natürlich für Lehrer extrem schwierig ist, diese Kompetenz zu lehren, wenn sie nicht mehr wissen, was sie... also wenn nicht mehr die Werkzeuge, um an die Information reinzukommen...
Ersprechen sie mal einen sputrufierten Satz, Herr Morawa.
Ich versuch's aber von vorne. Also, das ist irgendwie so mäßig, dass wenn es jetzt schon für Lehrer schwierig ist, dass sie mit den Computern auf die Reihe kriegen, dann können die natürlich mir auch nicht sagen, was ich gerade machen soll, oder?
So, war das besser?
Ja, das war schon mal viel besser.
Compatibel.
So, du musstest ganz lange warten jetzt am Telefon. Entschuldige. Aber du hast durchgehalten. Wie ist dein Name nochmal?
Martin. Martin, hallo. Genau, Hallöchen. Also ich bin in der 1. Klasse der Theresienschule, und wir hatten von Montag bis heute Projekt-Tage. Und ein Mitschüler von mir und ich, wir waren Projektleiter. Und haben dieses Mal, war das 2. Jahr, ein Internetprojekt gemacht und ist eigentlich sehr gut verlaufen. War ein bisschen stressig. Also ich beneide die Lehrer nicht, aber ja.
Du musstest deine Kollegen sozusagen unterrichten, deine Mitschüler.
Ja, meine Mitschüler, richtig. Also wir haben uns zum Glück auf die Oberstufe beschränkt. Ja, das ging eigentlich noch und war ganz okay. Na ja, also es gibt jedes Jahr halt ein Thema. Und dieses Jahr war das Thema Erde. Ja, und wir haben halt versucht, möglichst gute Informationen über unseren Planeten zu finden.
Wie erfolgreich war das?
Sehr erfolgreich und zwar eigentlich zu erfolgreich. Und zwar waren wir eigentlich schon so am Dienstag fertig. Und wussten nicht mehr so richtig, was wir heute machen sollen. Also ein paar Leute hatten halt ihre eigenen Rechner mitgebracht. Und dann ging es auf einmal erstmal ans Quake spielen. Und wenn so etwas erst mal losgebrochen ist, dann hat man selbst als Projektleitung ja dann nicht mehr viel möglich.
Das Medium hat euch verführt oder wie jetzt?
Na ja, klar, die wollten halt, also erstmal ging so eine kleine Landparty los. Und dann wollten sie natürlich auch mal sehen, wie man dann übers Internet Quake spielen kann.
Aber was für Informationen über den Planeten habt ihr denn gesammelt, das ihr so schnell fertig war? Weil der ist auch relativ groß, kann ich mir sagen.
Ich will erst noch eine andere Frage stellen. Wie viele Mädchen waren denn in dieser Gruppe?
Ja, eigentlich kein einziges.
Doch, doch, doch, einige, aber die sind irgendwie nur immer so nackt auf den Monitoren erschienen. Also war ich kein einziges und es ist ein bisschen merkwürdig, aber ja gut.
Merkwürdig.
Und habe ich es richtig verstanden, diese Projekt-Tage, die sind ohne Lehrer gewesen oder die Lehrer haben dazugeguckt oder wie lief das?
Nein, also die Lehrer, normalerweise machen natürlich meistens die Lehrer die Projekte und das können aber auch Schüler machen so und ja, das Projekt bestand halt nur aus Schülern, ja, seitens der Projektleitung und seitens der Teilnehmer. Und es kam natürlich mal ab und zu ein Lehrer vorbei, das war beim Queckspielen meistens sehr unpraktisch, aber ja.
Cool, aber eins interessiert uns jetzt doch, wie kommt es, dass ihr nach einem Tag fertig sein wollt, wenn ihr im Internet nach Informationen über die Erde sucht? Da seid ihr Jahre beschäftigt und noch nicht am Ende. Wie kommt das, dass ihr dann von Dienstag fertig wart?
Habt ihr im Grunde genommen nur festgestellt, dass der Planet rund ist oder was war?
Wir hatten letztendlich halt sieben Seiten Fett mit Informationen voll und irgendwann dachte man, macht das ja auch keinen Spaß mehr, aber und naja, dann haben wir es halt gelassen. Es war ja so, wir hatten, muss ich mal durchzählen, bestimmt acht Rechner oder so, die klebten dann halt über eine ISTN-Leitung dran, aber immerhin. Und ja, dann haben wir ungefähr immer so die Hälfte mal ein bisschen gesucht, dann kam so einiges zusammen, ja.
Na, ich denke, das reicht erstmal als Einblick für uns.
Ja, aber so, und dann hätte ich aber noch was und zwar, also wir besetzen das auch demnächst noch fort mit der Internet AG und mit Tüder von mir kümmert sich halt um die Client sozusagen, macht da seinen Windows 3.11 und so und ich lasse ihn da mal machen und ich mach den Linux Router und hab da aber ein Problem, ich hab zwar schon mal ein wunderbares Ritzkart konfigurieren können, also nie Probleme gehabt.
Ja, aber das ist jetzt gerade nicht der Platz.
Nee, du wolltest ja mal fragen, ob vielleicht ein Zuhörer mir mal melden könnte, der sich damit mehr aufschreibt.
Also du kannst die Frage auch einfach an mail.ccc.de schicken und da gibt es dann möglicherweise jemanden, der sie beantwortet, ich bekomme hier schon ein Handzeichen. Also ich darf jetzt da nichts weiter zu sagen.
Martin, dank dir.
So, Projekt am zweiten Tag beendet, weil alles was wir hier haben, ja, da.
Ja, ich will mal jetzt quack, okay, fertig. Tschüss.
Aber da lernt man ja auch ein bisschen was über Netzwerke.
Wir sind alle jetzt völlig baff.
So. Und? Und hast du mit deinen Schülern schon irgendwelche computertechnischen Erfahrungen?
Also erstmal, ich bin total der Computer-Nichtwisser, aber nicht, weil ich Lehrerin bin, weil ich Tanja bin.
Das ist ja kein Verbrechen.
Ich finde auch nicht, dass es ein Verbrechen ist. Ich denke, so pädagogisch gesehen ist es außerordentlich motivierend, für die Kinder zu wissen, dass da irgendwas ist, was die Lehrerin überhaupt nicht kann, überhaupt nicht weiß, sich super blöd anstellt und sie können es schon.
Hast du dann auch die Bereitschaft, dir das von denen erklären zu lassen?
Ah ja, hab ich schon. Ich kann ja so ein bisschen erzählen, also was der andere da erzählt hat, der da die Fortbildung gemacht hat. Bei uns laufen jetzt auch einige Fortbildungen, wir sind eine Grundschule. Und ich finde auch, wir sind eine ziemlich engagierte Grundschule. Also die Lehrer versuchen immer wieder neue Sachen aufzugreifen, neue Sachen zu machen. Jetzt sind wir so in Richtung Schule 2000 überlegen, bei uns viele Sachen, Klassen übergreifen. Also Schule 2000 ist ja auch ein Synonym für neue Arten zu unterrichten. Und da denken sich schon die Lehrer viel aus, obwohl die geldlichen Mittel dafür überhaupt nicht da sind. Und auch keine neuen Räume. Also wir versuchen Projekte zu machen, obwohl eigentlich die Strukturen dafür noch nicht da sind. Und denken uns da kreativ Dinge aus. Und es ist schon viel mehr Arbeit, aber das bereichert, also die meisten sind ja Lehrer geworden, weil sie ja was ändern wollten. Oder weil sie was bewirken wollten.
Das heißt, du sagst, es ist nicht so, dass Lehrer eigentlich nicht lernen wollen oder können, sondern dass es eher strukturelle Probleme sind, die da zugrunde liegen und dass die Motivation eigentlich da ist und auch der Spaß daraus erwächst.
Ich hab jetzt irgendwann vor kurzem so eine Sendung gesehen über Lehrer. Und es war eine Reportage, die war sogar zweiteilig. Die erste hat mich total geärgert. Und fertig und komm mit den Kindern nicht mehr.
Also erstmal die Bestandsaufnahme war richtig.
Und die zweite Sendung fand ich schon so lachhaft, dass ich die mir sogar ganz angesehen hab. Und so muss ich sagen, Lehrer sind schon eine spezifische Art von Menschen.
Beschreib doch mal.
Das musst du jetzt ein bisschen näher erklären allerdings.
Also bestimmte, also ich pass immer auf, dass es bei mir nicht so wird. Aber ich merke also zum Beispiel so, sagen Lehrer unheimlich oft. In unterschiedlichen Zulagen. Also immer so am Ende oder am Anfang. Und manchmal so eher so Säufzermäßig oder so aufbauend. Dann sind denke ich Lehrer schon darauf angewiesen, ziemlich viel zu planen und zu strukturieren.
Das heißt, du würdest, könnte ich sagen...
Und da steht einigen Lehrern Spontanität. Weil das bei mir jetzt umgekehrt ist. Also ich bin eher ein extrem spontaner Mensch, der sich immer wieder einfängen muss zu planen und zu strukturieren. Und von daher hoffe ich, dass ich so einen Ausgleich habe. Aber ich denke so, dass so mit meinen Kollegen, wenn ich so beobachte, sind da so bestimmte Sachen. Also wenn sie dann was geplant haben und es klappt nicht, dann sind sie schon ziemlich, wie will man sagen, teilweise ziemlich fertig. Und es ist, ich denke, es ist schon ein harter Beruf.
Hast du denn den Eindruck, dass dir da so eine Art Erwartungshaltung entgegenströmt? Oder warum muss man sich da so schrecklich viel vorbereiten?
Naja, guck mal, Lehrer sein bedeutet ja schon ein bisschen Entertainer sein. Du stehst da vor Kindern und am Anfang, also jetzt denke ich, habe ich keine Disziplinprobleme. Aber am Anfang hatte ich harte Disziplinprobleme. Und ich denke, ich wollte so locker und so Kumpel. Das war so mein Ansatz. Es ging einfach überhaupt nicht. Und dann war ich total streng und ganz viel Strafen gegeben und nur so ganz klare Linien. Und ich habe mich so unwohl gefühlt in meiner Rolle. Und die Kinder waren super zufrieden mit mir und ich ganz unzufrieden mit der Art, wie ich unterrichte. Und dann irgendwann habe ich so eine Art gefunden, also das ich denke ich Autorität habe, aber nicht autoritär bin und noch eine Menge Witze machen kann und Humor haben kann und das mir Spaß macht und den Kindern auch. Aber das hängt auch damit zusammen, dass ich schon eine Menge Fortbildung mache, nur nicht in Richtung Computer. Aber wir haben bei uns, das ist ja das was euch interessiert, also wir haben bei uns mehrere Computer, wie soll ich sagen, Richtungen gefunden, wo wir erstmal Computer kriegen. Wir haben erstmal von Eltern teilweise welche spendiert gekriegt, das läuft ganz lange. Und dann gibt es da glaube ich eine Aktion, die heißt Kids oder sowas. Und gibt es noch andere Möglichkeiten an Computer ranzukommen, indem man Computer austauscht. Und dann gibt es wohl noch eine Möglichkeit an Internet ranzukommen. Und es ist aber alles, also diese ganze Sache, läuft darauf hinaus, dass unsere Direktorin unheimlich viel Papierkram und Telefonate machen muss, um da irgendwie an diese Projekte ranzukommen. Und ich seh sie ja auch, sie ist mindestens täglich zwei Stunden dabei, irgendwo zu telefonieren, zu schreiben. Dann gibt es immer solche blöden Listen auszufüllen, weiß ich. Klar, denn die November-Statistik muss gemacht werden, und keiner weiß was das ist. Früher hieß sie wohl Oktober-Statistik.
Der Fünf-Jahres-Plan.
Tanja, du unterrichtest doch Religion, ne?
Ja, genau.
Gerade da wär es doch super spannend, sich da mal ein bisschen näher mit auszusetzen. Ich mach ja viel Freiarbeit.
Ich versuch viel, was schwer ist, weil ich hab immer diesen 45-Minuten-Takt. Davon wollen wir jetzt auch in den Jahren 2000 von diesem 45-Minuten-Takt weggehen, sondern das ist ja so zwei Stunden hintereinander, da kannst du ja so Projekte machen.
Boah, zwei Stunden?
Du denkst ja, das ist ja ganz schwer, ne? Aber im Grunde genommen ist es ja so, ein Kind hat die Motivation, von Anfang an zu lernen. Und normalerweise, wenn du so ein kleines Kind, wenn du so ein kleines Kind beobachtest, das so zwei Jahre alt ist, da sitzt er und spielt total lange an irgendeiner Sache rum. Total lange, es hat ganz lange Ausdauer dafür. Und es hat irgendwas gelernt. Und dann sitzt es ganz lange an so einem Baustein und arbeitet damit. Weiß ich, so zwei Stunden hintereinander, bis er es fertig hat. Und damit ist fertig. Und dann macht er was anderes und arbeitet aber auch sehr lange daran. Und wenn du Projektunterricht machst, das bedeutet nicht, dass du dann zwei Stunden dahinter stehst und die ganze Zeit Entertainer bist. Das ist das Gegenteil. Du erklärst den Kindern was und gibst denen auch genügend Zeit, sich damit auseinanderzusetzen. Und das kannst du machen, indem du ihnen... Also ich versuch das immer so zu machen, indem ich diese letzte Phase der sogenannten Erarbeitung, die dauert ja meistens irgendwie so nach dem alten 45, irgendwie so Einarbeitung, dann... Also du stellst vor, um was es geht, dann setzt du dich mit den Kindern auseinander und dann sollen sie selber erarbeiten. Und dann so in 15 Minuten Takt. Und die Erarbeitungsphase ist dann durch der Arbeitsbogen. Du kannst es aber auch so machen, dass du es mit denen zusammen so besprichst, irgendwie möglich so, dass es spannend ist. Und dann gibst du denen eine ganze Stunde mit unterschiedlichen Medien und Materialien, wo sie sich damit auseinandersetzen können. Und da wäre natürlich der Computer ganz klasse, wo, wenn du so hinten, das haben wir nämlich jetzt ein paar Räume, also ein paar Klassen haben wir das, hinten sind dann zwei bis drei Computer. Da setzen sich dann die Kinder, die gerne wollen, hin und suchen, was sie daraus finden. Es geht natürlich am besten, wenn du zwei Stunden hast.
Wann hast du zum letzten Mal was von einem Schüler gelernt?
Jeden Tag lern ich was von einem Schüler.
Ah, nicht das Allgemeine.
Weißt du, in welcher Art und Weise?
Dass dir der oder die ganz direkt irgendwas gezeigt oder erklärt hat.
Ich hab letztens das Bild vom Picasso mir angeguckt mit den Kindern. Also da hab ich wirklich viel nachgedacht darüber. Und zwar Gernika wegen des Krieges. Und da ist ja dieses berühmte Bild, also dieser Ausschnitt, wo die eine Hand diese Blume hält und dieses kaputte Schwert. Genau, und da haben wir drüber gesprochen, was diese Blume bedeutet und ganz viel. Und allgemein kommt so Liebe, Glück, bla, bla. Und da hat eben ein Mädchen gesagt, na, auf Gräbern sind immer Blumen drauf. Und das bedeutet, dass da Tod und Leben eins ist. Und mir ist nie aufgefallen, dass auf Gräbern deswegen Blumen drauf sind.
So, wir müssen ja noch die anderen Lehrer und Lehrerinnen, die jetzt an der Schlange stehen hier und wir rannehmen. Aber? Da ist jetzt gerade so ein Begriff gefallen, nämlich dieses Kits, was da heißt, Computer in die Schulen. Das ist eine Initiative hier aus Berlin. Es gibt ja noch so ein paar andere Begriffe. Das eine ist Schulen ans Netz. Das ist eine Initiative, die ist schon ein bisschen älter. Schulen ans Netz ist ja auch so ein Basswort, oder so ein Begriff einfach, der erst mal nicht so viel sagt. Das ist auch eine Initiative, zum Beispiel von der Telekom. Und da ging es darum, dass die Schulen dann einen Internetanschluss kriegen, also irgendwie einen ESDN-Anschluss und vielleicht aus einem Multimedia-PC hingestellt kriegen. Dazu gibt es dann noch einen Dienst vom Wind-Shuttle, also vom deutschen Forschungsnetz. Und da gibt es die Möglichkeit, dass Schulen da auch so eine Einwahlmöglichkeit wie eben über AOL oder irgendwelche anderen Provider in Berlin's NABU vielleicht einfach so eine Einwahl kriegen. Und das ist für Schulen auch kostenlos. Daneben gibt es ja auch noch das Offene Deutsche Schulnetz. Das ist mehr aus Kapazitätsgründen für E-Mail-Geschichten. Das heißt, die haben dann noch diese schule.de-Adressen vergeben, die dann für Homepages. Das heißt also, die Ausrede an, dass es da irgendwie keine Möglichkeiten gibt, die kann man eigentlich nicht mehr gelten lassen. Und in Berlin haben wir jetzt noch zusätzlich die Möglichkeit, über dieses Kids-Projekt, einmal diese Onschüss-Geschichte, dass es da also die Möglichkeit gibt, alte Hardware gegen neue auszutauschen. Also alte Hardware ist ja auch ein Problem.
Was ist das? Onschüss?
Onschüss ist eine Inzutive. Das heißt, wir haben also alte Computer-Hardware, meinetwegen zwei 86er oder vielleicht drei 86er, die weggegeben werden, zum Ausschlachten, Umbauen, Neueinrichten, wie auch immer. Und die Schule kriegt dafür neue, schicke, zeitgemäße PCs.
Cool, das mach ich jetzt auch.
Das ist eine Initiative von Kids, also im Rahmen dieses Kids-Projektes läuft das. Und was steckt dahinter? Dieses Kids-Projekt ist von einer Senats-Schulverwaltung, möchte ich jetzt nichts weiter sagen, von der schönen Senats-Schulverwaltung initiiert. Da ist die Telekom mit bei für die Telefongeschichten, also ISDN-Verbindungen und eben auch dieses Schulnetz. Es gibt also zwei Arten von Wegen, wie wir Schulen teilnehmen können. Nämlich einmal über T-Online, das heißt, sie kriegen einen ISDN-Anschluss und auch einen PC. Oder sie können sich an diesem Netz-in-Netz, das ist das Berliner Schulnetz, beteiligen. Und da erzählt uns jetzt der Markus Geschehler mal was dazu.
Das Berliner Schulnetz ist eine Variante zu dem, was bisher als Kommunikationsbasis für Schulen gedacht war. Bisher hat man klassisch einfach das Internet benutzt, man hat sich einen Provider gesucht und hat dann in großem Maße Internet-Anschlüsse in Schulen gebracht. Also Einwahlanschlüsse, sodass die Schule verhalten hat wie ein ganz normaler Nutzer bei ALT Online, wie auch immer der Provider heißt. Wir sind einen zweiten Weg gemeinsam mit der Deutschen Telekom gegangen und haben auf der Basis eines Projektes, was hier in Berlin entwickelt worden ist, nämlich Promenius, ein Prototyp eines Berliner Schulnetzes entwickelt, mit dem wir versuchen werden, in den nächsten drei Jahren 100 Schulen zu versehen. Wir bauen also ein, was für normale Betriebe nichts Neues ist, ein Wide Area Network auf, sodass man im Endstadium 100 Schulen miteinander über das Wide Area Network kommunizieren können, einen Ausgang ins Internet haben, aber eben auch projektbezogen miteinander arbeiten können. Und wir werden nach drei Jahren mal vergleichen, wo bei den Schulen das Internet nutzen, wo bei den Schulen, die das Schulnetz, also das Schulweite Intranet wie bei den Schulen nutzen, einmal die Kosten, aber auch der Nutzen ist.
Telefontechnisch machen wir mal eine kleine Pause, es ist jetzt übrigens genau 0 Uhr und damit herzlich willkommen im neuen Tag und beim Chaos Radio Computer Club Berlin, wo wir Fritz ihren letzten Mitmach um einen Monat zu hören. Und wir reden über Schulen, über Kompetenzen und über Medien.
Wer uns diesen ganzen Schlamassel eigentlich eingeprockt hat, weil wir haben ja jetzt viel heute ein bisschen gehört, haben ja Leute angerufen, wie das in den Schulen so ist, bzw. eben nicht ist, mit den Schulen und dem Internet. Und das Ganze hat einen historischen Hintergrund. Und das gibt sozusagen auch, naja, ich würde nicht sagen, einen Schuldigen zu benennen, aber so ungefähr. Es gab ja mal sowas wie die Bundespost. Und dann gab es die sogenannte Telekommunikationsderegulierung, um nicht zu sagen die Verkommerzialisierung dieser ganzen Angelegenheit. Und damals gab es im Bundestag mal einen sogenannten Bund-Länder-Streit über das Wegerecht. Es ist ja so, dass es sozusagen zu diskutieren gar nicht, wer darf dann eigentlich hier das Kabel unter der Erde verbuddeln, um da irgendwie Internet und was nicht alles durchfließen zu lassen. Für sich lag dieses Wegerecht bei der Bundespost und dann zunächst einmal bei den Kommunen. Das heißt, normalerweise wäre es zu gewesen, dass jede Stadt selbst entscheiden dürfte, wer dann da was macht. Und es gab damals die Idee, dass sie das ja so machen könnten, dass wenn irgendein Unternehmen jetzt sagen wir mal in Berlin irgendwie die Erde aufbuddeln will und da Karren verlegen will, dann könnte Berlin einfach sagen, könnt ihr machen, kein Problem. Aber Auflage ist, ihr müsst alle unsere Gebäude, zum Beispiel alle Schulen dafür umsonst anschließen. Das ist sozusagen der Preis, den wir zahlen müssen. Das wäre durchaus ein gangbares Modell gegeben. Und dem gegenüber stand sozusagen das Ländermodell, das heißt eine zentrale Vergabe der Wegerechte gegen Geld. Und da die Kassen der Kommunen immer leer waren, bzw. die immer pleite sind, hat es im Bundestag mehr oder weniger diese Streitdebatte gegeben. Und an dieser Stelle kam dann die Telekom und sagte, ja, die Sache mit den Ländern und das sie die Schulen vernetzen wollen, das ist ja durchaus verständlich. Aber das muss man ja nicht so machen, sondern wir machen jetzt das Projekt Schulen ans Netz. Wir geben 27 Millionen Mark dafür aus, alle Schulen an die Datenautobahn anzuschließen. Das klang alles ganz toll. Allerdings bedeutete das nicht etwa, dass alle Schulen jetzt eben umsonst einen Internetanschluss gekriegt haben und damit sozusagen man tatsächlich über das Problem nicht mehr hätte reden müssen, sondern das ganze hieß, dass sie einmalig einen kostenlosen, sozusagen erst mal T-Online-Anschluss, im Sinne von die Anschlussgebühr wurde ihnen erlassen gelegt bekommen, um dann kostenpflichtig zu den T-Online-Tarifen eben ein Internet zugang zu haben, was natürlich überhaupt nicht heißt, dass irgendeine Schule sich das auf Dauer leisten kann, weil das natürlich vollgefasst sind, abgesehen davon, dass damit auch die PCs und die Rechnerausstattung alles überhaupt nicht drin ist. Und aus diesem Projekt Schulen am Netz ist dann ja, was ist daraus geworden?
Na ja, Schulen ans Netz gibt es immer noch. Es ist mittlerweile die vierte Ausschreibungsrunde und was man nun bezahlen muss und was man bekommt. Das variiert ja auch. Aber gerade in Berlin ist nun mal der Deal so, dass Kids das Geld von Schulen ans Netz verwaltet. Daher kommen die ganzen Gelder, die die Schulselatorin hat. Und dafür aber auch bestimmte Auflagen bekommen hat, wofür sie dieses Geld wie verwendet. Also sagen wir mal, sanngerecht das Geld verwendet. Vielleicht kann Frank da ja noch mehr zu sagen, was die Schulen angeboten bekommen.
Es sieht also so aus, dass die Lottogesellschaft Berlin-Brandenburg einen sehr großen Teil dazu gegeben hat. Ein Teil davon sind aber auch tatsächlich diese SAN-Gelder. Und die Schulen müssen sich mit einem Projekt sozusagen dafür bewerben und kommen dann eben in Genuss dieses Internet-Anschlusses und auch eine Hardware-Ausstattung, sei es jetzt irgendwie...
Im Moment Internet oder T-Online-Anschluss?
Ja, es gibt halt diesen T-Online-Anschluss, das ist für die einfachen Schulen, sag ich mal, und dieses Schul-Intranet. Was denn aber danach dann daraus wird, ist noch nicht ganz klar. Es ist natürlich geplant, das weiterzuführen, aber jetzt geht es laut Kids eben erstmal darum, diesen Bedarf eigentlich auch festzustellen. Das heißt, man gibt den Schulen dann erstmal irgendwie ganz viel Internet und sagt, macht mal, wir gucken mal, was es denn so alles kostet, wie viel ihr da verbraucht. Und danach haben wir sozusagen einen Dollwert und können dann auch irgendwie neu verhandeln.
Und das ist das gleiche, was sie schon bei der ersten Runde gesagt haben. Und da fragt sich doch der geneigte Leser, warum sie bei der vierten immer noch da sind, wo sie bei der ersten waren.
Naja, das ist bei Comenius ja nicht anders. Comenius ist ja nun auch nicht mehr der erste Versuch, dieses Schul-Intranet-High-Speed-Wide-Area-Network zu etablieren. Und jetzt mal weg von Telekom und Schulen, die Meinung des Chaos Computer Clubs zu diesem Thema, der da schon etwas länger beobachtet ist. Da fällt auch eiskalt dieses gelbe Buch vom Himmel. Sie hätten mal jemanden fragen sollen. Das ist alles mit einer derartigen Inkompetenz bis jetzt vonstattengegangen. Und es funktioniert nicht richtig.
Im Grunde genommen muss man ganz klar sagen, Schulen als Netz ist nichts weiter als eine Marketing-Maßnahme. Es geht nicht darum, dass da tatsächlich irgendwie die Schüler danach Zugang zum Internet haben, sondern es geht darum, dass ein Unternehmen in den Ruf kommt, sie hätten etwas für die Vernetzung der Schulen. Genau.
Das Unternehmen hat Bedürfnisse erkannt und hat da eine gute Werbung drauf gesetzt.
Aber für die Schulen...
Das wäre ja auch soweit okay, wenn daraus was werden würde. Ich frag mich, kann mir jemand erklären, warum wir... Erstens, warum brauchen wir so ein Wide Area Network, was dann nur die Schulen angeht? Also das im Grunde genommen, können wir ja das Internet dafür nutzen. Da kann es ja auch von mir aus auch irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, Webpages geben, die dann nur für die Schulen zugänglich sind oder keine Ahnung, mir wurscht.
Nee, das hängt ein bisschen damit zusammen. Es gibt theoretisch ansatzweise in dieser Stadt, es gab mal das LIT, das Landesamt Informationstechnik, wenn ich es richtig buchstabiere. Und die haben also ein Glasfasernetz, historischerweise sozusagen gehabt, das alle, mehr oder weniger alle öffentlichen Gebäude erreicht. Das sind also beispielsweise die Vernetzung der Einwohner, Meldeämter, der Rathäuser und so weiter und so fort. Es hat schon standardmäßig, auch in zu alten Bundespostzeiten, immer die Ausnahmeregelung gegeben, dass also nicht nur die Bundespost, sondern auch die Länder für ihre eigenen Bedürfnisse Kabel in der Erde verlegen dürfen. Und eben nicht nur die Post, das Monopol da hat. Und aus dieser Überlegung heraus, falls es da tatsächlich ein paar Glasfaserstränge gibt, kommt wohl das Konzept, da irgendwie ein Wahn draus zu machen. Weil das ist im Grunde genommen schon ein Wahn. Bloß hat das eben nichts damit zu tun. Oder hat das leider nicht den Effekt, dass man da Internet hat.
Und da liegt das jetzt an diesen ganzen Konzepten, die ja nun auch schon eine Weile besprochen werden, dass man nicht einfach sagen kann, als Land Berlin zum Beispiel, wir setzen uns mit einem großen Provider zusammen. Oder auch, zumindest von der Größe her, meine ich jetzt nicht unbedingt die Umsätze, sondern einfach von dem, was er technisch leisten kann. Und sagen wir verhandeln eine Pauschale für die Schulen, die daran teilnehmen.
Das gibt es in ganz vielen Städten. Gerade, weil eine Stadt danach schreit. Denn eine Stadt hat ja eher so ein Stadtnetz wie Andis beschrieben hat, als jetzt irgendwo auf dem Plattenland, wobei die es wahrscheinlich auch haben. Aber ich meine, es kennt jeder von früher, dass die Schulen alle die gleiche Vorwahl hatten und dass die Behörden eine Vorwahl hatten. Und es gab diese Netze ja auch schon. Da hätte man irgendwo einen Rechner dranhängen können und dann hätten die schon mal anfangen können. Aber das war erstens eines Verkaufens, und zweitens konnten sich vor lauter Kompetenzranglei nicht einigen. Es gibt wenige Städte, die das geschafft haben. Also im Ruhrpott haben es einige geschafft, Göttingen hat es geschafft und ähnliche Städte.
Ich denke, ein wesentliches Problem dabei ist, dass es tatsächlich Firmen und Unternehmensinteressen gibt, die da ganz viel Geld einbringen. Microsoft hat da massiv Interesse, die Telekom selbstverständlich, all die Firmen, wir haben es vorhin in dem Beispiel gehört, diese hochqualifizierten Unternehmen, die dann ganz doll die Anbindung da mit proprietären, kommerziellen Produkten machen, das ist letzten Endes ein Verfahren, das zum Scheitern verurteilt ist, weil es nicht auf allgemein zugänglichen, kostenlosen und frei verfügbaren Systemen basiert. Das könnte man selbstverständlich realisieren. Dann bliebe nämlich im Prinzip nur noch die Kosten für die Anschaffung der Hardware und die Kosten für den Zugang der Leitung. Ich denke, das kann man unter Lehrmittel ohne weiteres finanzieren.
Na du kannst natürlich, sowas könnte glaube ich schon. Ich meine, dass der Firmen Interesse daran haben, ist normal. Und es wäre auch alles gar nicht so schlimm, wenn es die Kompetenz gäbe zu sagen, gut, wir wollen von euch das und das, wir fordern das und das. Und dann können wir auch gerne teilweise eure Produkte benutzen.
Das hätte ich nicht gemerkt, weil die Produkte geben, die haben ja die Macht zu bestimmen, was passiert. Also muss man überlegen, sie wissen bei Sun ganz genau, dass jetzt schon auf ihrer Webpage, erst auf heute Nachmittag, 149 Schulen bei Sun dran sind. Wenn sie jetzt 100 wieder in ihr lokales Netzwerk nehmen, jeder erfindet wieder was neu und irrigerweise sie jetzt selber auch dreimal das Gleiche. Und dann wird es ja für die Schulen, wie wir eben gehört haben, auch nicht leichter, denn die müssen für jeden Furz, den sie bekommen wollen, immer wieder neue Beantragungen schreiben. Wenn sie da sagt, pro Tag zwei Stunden macht sie Papierkram, die Direktorin, genauso ist das. Du musst ja als Direktor oder als Informatiklehrer mittlerweile Projektmanager sein, um dein Geld über und deine Projekte zu akquirieren, um herauszufinden, wer mit wem, was, wann, wo, wievielte Runde.
Anke, ich glaube, man sollte sowieso mal ein paar Sätze zu dem sagen, was du machst, weil sich vielleicht der eine oder andere Hörer oder die eine oder andere Hörerin jetzt fragt, woher kommt deine Kompetenz und dein Wissen hier in diesem Bereich?
Naja, eigentlich aus der Mailbox-Szene. Und dieses Wissen hat sich gepaart mit zwei Examsarbeiten, die ich schreiben musste, damit ich ordentliche Lehrerin werden konnte. Die bin ich jetzt hier in Berlin.
Da warten wir die ganze Zeit darauf, dass einer anruft und dann sitzt sie schon hier.
Naja, aber vielleicht gibt es ja schon noch welche, die was dazu zu sagen haben.
Aber das ist gar nicht so blöd. Vielleicht haben ja jetzt die Lehrer und Lehrerin weniger Angst. Wenn eine Kollegin hier sitzt.
Ja, hier sitzt auch eine.
Ich springe auch ein.
Telefonieren wir noch ein bisschen?
Oder gibt es noch was, was wir noch zu bereden haben?
Nö, können ruhig mal nach Lehrern fischen.
Es gibt da schon noch was, was wir zu bereden haben. Aber das können wir auch mit den Lehrern, ne?
Lieber Leute, wir hängen ziemlich lange in der Leitung.
Wenn es noch Lehrer gibt, die anrufen wollen, dann sagen wir mal die Nummer, dass die 033...
Wollen wir das mal anders formulieren?
Hallo, 0331 mit Potsdam, 70 97 110, 70 97 110. Zähl mal ruhig, ich gucke inzwischen, ob hier jemand ist.
Für die Lehrer ist es vielleicht auch schon ein bisschen spät jetzt. Die haben morgen wieder Schule, ne?
Für die Schüler auch.
Nein, die Schüler sind jünger, die sind...
Leistungsfähiger.
Die hängen auch vom Computer. Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Ja, hallo, hier ist der Marco.
Marco, bist du Lehrer?
Nee, ich bin kein Lehrer. Ähm, ich bin so was, wie andere Leute Schüleradministratoren nennen würden.
Aha, an welcher Schule?
Am Seines Pauling-Gymnasium in Berlin Köpenick.
Das heißt, du verwaltest da ein Netzwerk, oder?
Ja, mit einem anderen Schüler zusammen, mit meinem Kumpel.
Und du bist auch Schüler?
Ich bin auch Schüler, ja. Und wir haben im Oktober letzten Jahres ein neues Netzwerk bekommen, wo so NT auf dem Server und Windows 98 auf den Schülerrechnern vorinstalliert war. Und unser Informatiklehrer hat damals gesagt, er war nur jemand, der sich sehr gut mit Unix auskannte, mit unserem alten Netz und so, aber von Windows 95, 98, NT relativ wenig Ahnung hatte. Und hat gesagt, bevor er das jetzt alle in den Sand setzt, nimmt er ein paar Leute, die wenigstens ein bisschen Ahnung davon haben und versucht dann dabei selbst zu lernen. Also eigentlich mehr oder weniger so ein Gegenbeispiel zu den Schulen, die vor Hönsel waren. Von wegen die Administratoren haben da alle keine Lust zu lernen und wollen nur das, was sie können.
Was habt ihr für Erfahrungen da gemacht? Läuft das gut?
Ja, also es läuft im Moment richtig klasse. Wir sind also auch eine Modellschule von diesen Projektschulen ans Netz und haben eben damals einen ESDN-Anschluss gekriegt mit einem Grundbudget von 1500 Mark oder so, was noch ein bisschen reicht.
Im Monat?
Nee, also insgesamt, die wir so haben, die wir halt noch telefonieren können, wo immer noch eine ganze Menge übrig ist, denke ich.
Tatsächlich?
Und wir haben halt auch in diesem Projekt Programme bekommen wie Microsoft Exchange Server und Proxy Server, so eine Sachen, um halt auch richtig die Schüler ins Netz zu bringen. Haben das alles soweit bis jetzt installiert. Also wir haben jetzt auch eine Internet AG, wo dann immer in einer Woche die Schüler kommen können, wild im Netz surfen oder Hausaufgaben vorbereiten, sonst was. Also für so eine Schüler, die zu Hause selbst keinen Rechner haben und sowas machen können.
Marco, was war denn der Grund, dass ihr, du hast ja gerade gesagt, ihr hattet ein Unix-Netz. Und jetzt war das praktisch dieses Schulen ans Netz-Projekt, was euch dann ein bisschen dazu gezwungen hat, auf den ganzen Microsoft-Kram umzusteigen, weil eigentlich logischer wäre dann, um Kosten zu sparen, Umstieg auf Linux. Und hätte man ja genauso gut so machen können.
Naja, also das war, das hing ein bisschen damit zusammen, mit diesem neuen Netz, das wir bekommen haben.
Also mit dem, was von der Telekom da kam.
Ich weiß nicht, es kam auch im Rahmen von irgendeinem Projekt, aber ich weiß nicht genau, ob dieses Schulen ans Netz war. Der größte Teil davon war vom Senat gesponsert und so.
Das heißt, ihr musstet also auch den Windows benutzen?
Ja, es war mir doof. Wir waren eigentlich relativ zufrieden damit. Vor allen Dingen läuft es jetzt. Nach wie vielen Monaten? Naja, laufen tut es seit Anfang an. Unser Lehrer guckt uns immer an, wenn wir sagen, wir könnten jetzt mal dit machen oder so. Und der sagt immer, das läuft gerade so gut. Warum wollt ihr jetzt immer was Neues?
Was kein schlechter Einwand ist.
Was es dann immer dazu führt, dass wir 10 Minuten brauchen, um etwas neu zu installieren, und danach 10, 2 Wochen, damit es dann wieder läuft.
Aber habt ihr gar nicht den Anspruch, auch mal vielleicht etwas anderes kennenzulernen, wie z.B. Linux oder sowas?
Naja, das Problem ist, dass wir schon sehr viel Zeit darin investiert haben, dass wir so weit sind wie jetzt. Wir haben es so weit, dass für jeden Schüler in einer Schule, der Lust hat, kann bei uns eine E-Mail-Adresse bekommen. Kann sich jeden Tag dahin kommen, kann da E-Mails schreiben, selber welche bekommen, abholen usw. Und dieses gesamte System, was ja nun doch recht unverreichend inzwischen ist, wieder über einen Haufen zu werfen, um Linux auszuprobieren, ist ein bisschen riskant, würde ich sagen.
Kannst du dir vorstellen, dass es vielleicht unheimlich viel Zeit Verschwendung gewesen ist, das mit Microsoft-Produkten zu machen, weil es was anderes gibt, was nicht nur billiger ist, sondern auch viel einfacher funktioniert, an der Stelle zumindest?
Na, wie sagen wir mal so, mit der E-Mails-Sache hatten wir es sehr einfacher. Wir hatten vorher ein relativ einfacher Programm, was bloß so eine Testversion war, für 30 Tage, aus dem Netz. Da haben wir dann vielleicht eine halbe Stunde gesessen, dann hat das alles funktioniert. Unter Windows, ja. Und es war natürlich alle sehr schön. Nach 30 Tagen war das aber vorbei. Und inzwischen haben wir halt kostenlos den Exchange-Server gekriegt bekommen.
Was hältst du davon, dass, oder wie findest du das, dass die Schüler an eurer Schule jetzt an Programme, an Software gewöhnt werden, die, wenn sie die im privaten Leben benutzen möchten, weil sie die jetzt gelernt haben, damit können sie umgehen, plötzlich Tausende von Mark bezahlen müssen. Weil sie Word benutzen wollen, weil sie Excel benutzen wollen, weil sie das Betriebssystem benutzen wollen, und die ganzen Komponenten, die damit zusammenhängen, und die kosten ein Schweinegeld. Und unsere Schulen in diesem Land haben sie darauf dressiert, auf dieses proprietäre Produkt eines kommerziellen Unternehmens sich festzulegen. Findest du das in Ordnung, oder siehst du da nicht auch vielleicht irgendwie ein gewisses...
Na ja, also einerseits schon, klar, gerade als Schüler, wenn man jetzt wirklich nichts anderes gewohnt ist, und gerade die Leute, die halt ein bisschen weniger Ahnung haben, die halt ihr gesamtes Computerwissen aus dem ITG-Unterricht haben, gerade die sind ja halt so eine Leute, die sich denn daran festhalten, an dem was sie mal gelernt haben, in dem Fall halt eben Office. Und da ist natürlich irgendwo schon unfair den Schülern gegenüber.
Ich finde es aber auch euch gegenüber unfair. Ihr hattet was, das war gut, das lief. Und es hätte euch ja auch mal jemand was schenken können, was dazu gepasst hat. Oder hätte. Na ja, ihr hattet doch ein funktionierendes System.
Das Unix-System.
Das Unix-System funktioniert auch immer noch. Wir haben jetzt im Moment Wehsysteme. Das alte System war halt ein Unix-System mit 386 Rechnern als Schülerrechner, die alle nicht mal eine Festplatte drin hatten. Und jetzt haben wir ein Netz, wo jeder Schülerrechner ein K6 266 ist oder so in dem Dreh. Die halt alle ausgerüstet sind mit einer 4 GB Platte und 32 fach CD-ROMs und so. Die größtenteils leider alle nicht benutzt werden. Aber halt man hat halt viel mehr Möglichkeiten. Und damit hat sich auch der gesamte Informatikunterricht inzwischen auf das neue Netz verlagert.
Marco, was war das für eine Schule? Und was hast du gesagt?
Linus Pauling Gymnasium.
Alles klar. Ich danke dir erstmal.
Schönen Abend.
Ja danke.
Wir sind jetzt natürlich in einer komplett anderen Diskussion auch mit dieser Microsoft-Geschichte.
Das war aber auch geplant eigentlich.
Das ist auch mehr als okay. Wir haben natürlich da das Problem, dass erstens wusste ja auch von uns, also ich sag mal von euch, niemand vor weiß ich wieviel Jahren, dass es so etwas wie Linux in der Form jemals geben wird. Also das ist natürlich ein Wunschraum gewesen und das ist auch eine großartige Geschichte nach wie vor. Aber Linux ist nach wie vor eine große Ausnahme in der Rangehensweise, wie man so ein Betriebssystem irgendwie mit vielen Programmierern weiterentwickeln kann und so weiter. Und da tut sich ja inzwischen auch einiges. Die Frage ist nur natürlich immer, welcher Hersteller hat Interesse zum Beispiel die Hardware zu verschenken? Das ist natürlich nur einer, der dann hofft, dass die Schüler auf seine Software gewünscht werden.
Was hier läuft, ist halt dieses Öllampenprinzip. Wie die Ölscheiche reich geworden sind, die Lampen zu verschenken. Dann wird sich der Bedarf nach dem Sprit schon einstellen. Und das Problem ist ein bisschen, dass die Diskussion oder überhaupt diese Bedürfnisse, wir brauchen Internet, dass das zumindest politisch leider nicht so war, dass die Kommunen gesagt haben, wir brauchen irgendwie Internet in den Schulen und so fort, sondern von vornherein waren die Marketingleute dieser großen Unternehmen ein bisschen schneller und haben gesagt, das ist unsere Chance, da einen Abseitsmarkt zu erschließen, von dem wir im Moment gerade noch träumen können.
Wobei ich noch mal was sagen wollte zu dem, was du eben gesagt hast, als das anfing mit Schulen ans Netz, Windows an die Schulen und so weiter. So ganz einfach ist es nicht, denn es gab genauso viele Leute, die bei der ersten Initiative mitgemacht haben, die Linux und Unix pushen wollten, wie es eine Telekom und ein Microsoft gab, die da mitgemacht haben. Nur die anderen waren in einem halben Jahr ungefähr ausgebotet. Es hat kaum noch einer mit dieser heiße CD gekämpft, weil sie einfach in Schlechtes, weil sie einfach an einen Verruf gekommen war bei den Leuten, die in der Schule damit arbeiten sollten, konnten. Und dann gab es halt eine Weile, wo man einfach das annahm, was man bekam. Das hat er ja auch eben so geschildert. Und ich glaube aber, jetzt schwenkt es langsam wieder um, muss ich schon sagen. Das Problem ist nur halt, dass, also wenn man einfach mal von dem Standpunkt ausgeht, dass es besser ist, wenn man ein Betriebssystem benutzt, was einfach langfristig billiger ist und andere Möglichkeiten bietet, ist die Frage natürlich, wie kann man jetzt was dagegen tun? Oder wie kann man die Leute dafür sensibilisieren, dass nicht weitere Projekte gestartet werden, die immer wieder in die gleiche Kerbe schlagen?
Haben wir da nicht auch so ein bisschen das Problem, also ich bin wirklich der Allerletzte, der in irgendeiner Form Microsoft da unterstützen will oder in Schutz nehmen will oder so, aber das ist ja tatsächlich auch so, dass erst in den letzten Jahren oder nicht sogar Monaten irgendwie Linux-Installationen vorlagen, mit denen man irgendwie klarkommt, auch wenn man nicht wirklich schon viel mit Computersystemen, mit verschiedensten Systemen gearbeitet hat.
Ja, Johnny, das ist aber mit Windows ganz genauso.
Das stimmt so nicht. Ich glaube, dass es immer noch ein Unterschied ist, wenn du zu Hause irgendwie Mac OS oder von mir aus auch Windows laufen hast und dann irgendwie an einen NT-Server gehst, als wenn du einen Linux-Server verdienst.
Johnny, aber da sind wir bei der Medienkompetenz. Medienkompetenz ist immer auch die Kompetenz der Wahl der Mittel. Und wenn du natürlich von klein auf, also jetzt nicht von klein auf, sondern als Jugendlicher an Microsoft-Produkte rangeführt wirst, Papi, die auf dem Rechner hat und so fort und so fort, dann wirst du das auch in der Schule verwenden und auch dafür plädieren, als kompetenter Ansprechpartner auch von Seiten der Schüler zu sagen, ne, den wollen wir haben, damit kennen wir uns aus. Das ist einfach nur das alte Streit zwischen Norton Commander und, wie hieß der, X3 Gold. Das, womit du angefangen hast, das benutzt du. Nur müssen wir hier objektive Grundlagen zugrunde legen und sagen, wo ist einfach der größere Sinn? Ist es sinnvoller, ein Produkt, das man bezahlen muss, zu verwenden? Oder ist es sinnvoll, ein Open Source Produkt zu benutzen, an dem ich reingucken kann, wie es funktioniert, ohne dass ich da irgendwelche Probleme habe, an dem anhand dessen ich die komplette Computerarchitektur auf Basis Betriebssystemsoftware und so weiter verstehen lernen kann, ohne dass mich das zusätzlich Geld kostet. Ein verschenktes Lehrmittel, an dem ich sogar Projekte machen kann, um das selbst zu erweitern, zu verbessern, mich an dieser Gemeinde beteiligen kann, als Schulprojekt dieses System mit weiter gestalten und entwickeln kann und gleichzeitig noch lerne, wie wichtig das, was Andi ganz zu Eingang sagte, diese Kooperation, Lesen, Schreiben und Kooperation. Gerade diese Kooperation heißt, sein Wissen weiterzugeben. Und Schulen haben meines Erachtens genauso wie Universitäten nicht nur den Auftrag, den Schülern, Studenten etwas beizubringen, sondern auch der Gesellschaft etwas zurückzuliefern. Und das ist doch in diesem Open Source-Gedanken wesentlich einfacher als Schüler und besser zu machen, als dass man jetzt proprietäre Produkte benutzt, die der Schüler, wenn er weiter damit arbeiten will, im Geschäftsleben, privat oder sonst wie, dann für teuer Geld bezahlen muss. Ich warte darauf, dass wir ein Produkt wie Microsoft School bekommen oder so etwas und ich kriege eine Krise, muss man ehrlich sagen.
Das ist also inhaltlich überhaupt kein Thema und überhaupt keine Frage, völlig klar. Es ist nur, denke ich, genauso klar, warum es so funktioniert. Weil zum Beispiel natürlich auch hinter einem Open Source-Betriebssystem einfach kein kommerzieller Gedanke steckt, der von einer Firma, die einfach, weiß ich nicht, wie viele Hundert Mitarbeiter losschickt und diese Idee verbreitet. In der Praxis sieht es auch so aus, dass sich teilweise schon Eltern bei den Schülern oder bei der Schule beschweren, wenn da irgendwie Linux unterrichtet, also wenn da mit Linux gearbeitet wird. Wie kommen sie denn dazu, den Leuten sowas beizubringen? Die brauchen später ein Büro, sie brauchen ein Office, sie brauchen Word, Excel und so weiter. Die Schüler sollen ja was fürs Leben lernen. Da beschweren sich tatsächlich Eltern, die können das einfach so nicht begreifen und da fehlt wahrscheinlich auch den Schulen die Argumentationsgrundlage dafür. Man muss sich das mal vorstellen, als wenn verschiedene Autohersteller jeweils eine bestimmte Benzinmarke hätten, mit der sie fahren oder so. Das ist irgendwie, ähm, weiß nicht...
Ja, bloß das Linux eben das Modell, das mit Luft fährt, so. Bloß, dass das Modell mit Luft leider nicht verpreistet ist auf den Straßen, weil die Erdholindustrie verhindert hat, daß irgendwie dieses Modell herauskommt.
Und man muss selber was dafür tun, das was wir eigentlich den Schülern beibringen sollten, nämlich zu lernen, dass man selber etwas tun muss für sich, für sein Weiterkommen, für seine Interessen, für seine eigene Motivation etwas tun muss, müssen die Schulen, die Lehrer, die Direktoren und dieses ganze System etwas dafür tun, um Linux zum Beispiel zu benutzen, um diesen Vorteil auch zu erfahren. Nicht einfach hingehen und das kaufen, das ist einfach zu primitiv. Da ist auch kein Anspruch dahinter. Ich finde, man sollte da auch mit dem Anspruch rangehen zu sagen, es gibt Alternativen, an denen man was lernen kann. Und da muss man den Aufwand treiben. Das ist sicher vielleicht ein bisschen aufwendiger, da erst mal sich reinzufinden, weil Windows kennt man, Linux vielleicht nicht, aber gerade sich dieser Herausforderung als Schulauftrag auch zu stellen und zu sagen, klar, wir haben auch ein gewisses Forschungsinteresse und wir haben auch das Interesse, uns diese Aufgabe zu stellen und sie umzusetzen, das finde ich unendlich wichtig.
Ich finde auch, man kann sowas ja auch parallel laufen lassen. Ich lasse das durchaus gelten, dass man sagt, man sollte vielleicht auch wissen, wie man in einem Windows-System umgeht, aber das ist ja auch kein Problem.
Ein paar Linux-Server und Windows rangeknimmt, klar.
Aber ihr seht ja, wie es läuft. Also wenn auf der einen Seite dann das Unix-Netzwerk steht und auf der anderen Seite das Windows-Netzwerk, dann gehen sie alle an die Windows-Rechner, weil die halt eben zur Zeit noch die Autos sind, die es in verschiedenen Farben mit den verschiedenen Innenausstattungen und mit den tollen Wechselbezügen gibt. Und das gibt es halt für Linux jetzt gerade mal am Anfang. Aber wenn ich zum Beispiel Kollegen höre, die sich irgendwelche Lehrmittel zulegen oder so, die gibt es nicht für Linux, die gibt es nicht für Unix, die gibt es nur für Windows. Die kann ich dann eben nur bedingt benutzen, wenn ich halt in der Schule mit Linux arbeite.
Da gibt es eine interessante Entwicklung.
Ja, ja, ja, aber ich bin ja nicht der Ansicht, dass es jetzt nicht positive Entwicklungen gibt. Aber noch sind wir in der Entwicklung.
Zu deinem Schonbezug-Modell habe ich mal eine Gegentät. Es könnte auch sein, dass es daran liegt, dass in erster Linie mal nicht die Schüler oder nicht diejenigen, die das technische Verständnis haben, die Entscheidung fällen, sondern diejenigen, die ohnehin, wie wir vorhin in dem Hörerbeitrag gehört haben, unendlich viel Zeit damit zu tun haben, sich in ihrer Rolle als Entertainer vorzubereiten. Und dann haben sie vielleicht noch wenige Minuten, um jetzt die Wahl eines Betriebssystems festzulegen. Und dann gibt es doch diese große bunte Verpackung da muss man nur irgendwie einen Betrachter legen und dann hat man das. Und das andere, ach da muss man irgendwie Bücher lesen und sich irgendwie reinlernen und oh Gott, da muss man was lernen. Ist das nicht auch ein bisschen Geistesfaulheit, wenn man sagt, hier ist ein Produkt, das muss ich nur kaufen und dann ist es bunty clicky und das andere, hm, da muss ich mich vielleicht möglicherweise auseinandersetzen.
Halt, volle Kanne, ich bekenne mich schuldig.
Man kann ja auch nicht wirklich feststehen, dass man für sowas in der Schule einen Fachmann braucht oder eine Fachfrau.
Die gibt es aber bis jetzt nicht. Die werden nicht bezahlt. Die werden einfach nur in ihrer Freizeit ackern, so wie wir es eben hatten. An der Uni gibt es Hilfskräfte, an der Schule gibt es überhaupt gar kein Geld dafür.
Da beißt sich die Katze doch ins Schwanz. Die werden wir auch nicht bekommen, diese Fachleute, wenn die ganzen Leute jetzt mit Windows an den Schulen verdummt werden. Dann werden wir niemals die Fachleute bekommen, die später das auch umsetzen können, Lehrer bekommen, die in der Schule schon solche Dinge gelernt haben und für die es dann ein leichtes ist zu sagen an der Schule, hey, kein Problem, mach ich, kann ich, weiß ich, wie es geht.
Worüber würden wir diskutieren, wenn die Geschichte Linux nicht wäre?
Wenn es Linux nicht gäbe?
Also nehmen wir mal, das geben wir bei FreeBSD diskutieren.
Ich würde immer noch über das diskutieren, worüber ich vor vier Jahren auch schon diskutiert habe, warum es eigentlich überall Geld für Technik gibt, nur an den Schulen nicht.
Darauf wollte ich nämlich ein bisschen zurückkommen, dass wir ein bisschen von dem Linux-Streit wegkommen, der sicher ein wichtiges, den wir auch sehr oft hier in der Sendung sowieso haben, und speziell in dem Fall natürlich macht da sehr viel Sinn. Aber, daß uns mal davon ausgehen, dass es kein kostenloses Betriebssystem, kein Open Source Betriebssystem gibt. Sondern einfach nur bei der Tatsache bleiben, dass einfach die ganzen Ansätze ja schon nicht da sind. Also es gibt weder Fachleute an den Schulen, die solche Entscheidungen überhaupt erst mal treffen können. Klar nimmt man dann immer das, was groß und bunt ist, und was einem sofort zugeschmissen wird.
Ich muss da unterbrechen, das ist der falsche Ansatz. Warum sollten wir davon ausgehen, dass es so etwas nicht gibt? Es gibt das, mit Grund. Das war wichtig, das musste kommen. Und das ist gekommen, weil es dafür einen Bedarf gibt.
Aber für die grundsätzliche Frage, warum es keine Fachleute gibt und warum sich Schulen nicht darauf einlassen, erst mal wieder hängt das.
Aber Johnny, das Problem ist, wenn wir jetzt anfangen zu jammern, es gibt kein Geld, die Politiker auf hoher Ebene haben es nicht begriffen und deswegen kann die arme kleine Schule nichts ausrichten, dann ist es eine Scheißdiskussion, weil dann landet man ganz schnell dabei, irgendwelche Politiker der ein oder anderen Legislaturperiode verantwortlich zu machen und das hilft einfach den Schulen nicht. Stopp Johnny! Und der Punkt ist doch einfach mal der, die Ausgangslage ist jetzt, es ist alles ziemlich blöd gelaufen, aber es gibt Schulen, es gibt Schüler, es gibt Lehrer, es gibt Open-Source-Betriebszene, es gibt Gottverdammtes Windows und es gibt jetzt irgendwie einen Handlungsbedarf und die Frage ist, was kann jetzt irgendwie der, die Lehrerin vor Ort, was können die Schüler vor Ort möglicherweise Kraft der Motivation irgendwie tun, im Kenntnis der Sachlage, so beschissen, wie auch immer sie ist.
Ich finde, das Problem setzt vorher an. Ich finde, das Problem setzt da an, dass man sich fragen muss, warum hat sich in vielen Bereichen einiges geändert und man passt sich an im Umgang mit bestimmten Dingen, aber im Schulbereich zum Beispiel tut sich seit Jahrzehnten gar nichts.
Johnny, wir haben das Problem, dass da nichts passiert, weil es vor 10, 15 Jahren diese Medienkompetenzschulen in den Schulen nicht gab. Als unsere Lehrer von heute damals noch Schüler waren. Und wir haben jetzt die Chance und die Pflicht, das umzusetzen. Unsere Gesellschaft hat die Pflicht, die kommende Lehrerschaft in die Kompetenz zu versetzen, das zu können. Und das geht garantiert nicht mit Microsoft-Produkten.
Es ist aber auch insgesamt ein Geldproblem. Man muss sich das mal vorstellen, wenn man wirklich alle Schulen mit guten Computern ausstatten will. Und vielleicht auch noch eine Administraturstelle dazu, weil auch ein Windows-Netzwerk, auch wenn es schön zum Klicken ist, man braucht einfach jemand, der sich da auskennt. Wenn dann 20 Rechner stehen, dann muss da einfach eine feste Stelle sein. Das hat die Praxis gezeigt. Und da ist es eigentlich auch egal, ob sich dieser jemand mit Linux beschäftigt oder mit Windows. Da hat es auch einfach gesagt, dass das eine riesige Summe Geld kostet.
Hausmeister und Putzkolonne muss auch sein.
Das gehört halt heute dazu. Das ist was Steine gerade sehr richtig und sehr auffordernd gesagt hat, nämlich, dass man spätestens anfangen muss, diese Kompetenzen zu schaffen und das Versäumte nachzuholen. Ich denke, genau da wird man anknüpfen. Nach dem Fritz-Korz-Info. Warte.
Kommunikationsprobleme.
Und das, obwohl wir überhaupt keine E-Mail benutzen.
Wenn.
Eine Rakete der NATO ist am Abend statt in Jugoslawien in der bulgarischen Hauptstadt Sufja eingeschlagen. Wie der Rundfunk des Landes berichtete, wurde ein Wohnhaus schwer beschädigt. Opfer gab es keine. Unter den Einwohnern brach jedoch Panik aus. Bulgariens Staatspräsident Steuernow unterrichtete das Hauptquartier der NATO in Brüssel. Luftalarm. In mehreren Städten Jugoslawiens mussten die Bewohner erneut die Luftschutzkeller aufsuchen. Die Sirenen ermordeten in Belgrad, sowie in Nis, Novisat und Kragujevac. Auch nahe der Kleinstadt Sudulica soll es einen neuen Angriff gegeben haben. Dort war gestern eine NATO-Bombe in ein Wohngebiet eingeschlagen. Etwa 20 Menschen kamen dabei ums Leben. Truppenbesuch. US-Präsident Clinton will in der kommenden Woche die amerikanischen Luftwaffenbasen in Deutschland besuchen. Vom rheinland-pfälzischen Stützpunkt Spandalem aus starten Tarnkappenbomben bei der US-Armee zu Angriffen auf Jugoslawien. Clinton folgt einer Einladung von Bundeskanzler Schröder. Diplomatie. UNO-Generalsekretär Anan traf gestern Abend in Moskau ein. Er will mit dem russischen Präsidenten Jelzin über ein Ende des Kosovo-Krieges sprechen. Aufschub. Die PLO hat darauf verzichtet, am 4. Mai einen unabhängigen Staat auszurufen. Grund sind die Wahlen in Israel Mitte Mai.
Sport.
Fußball. Deutschland hat das Länderspiel gegen Schottland 0 zu 1 verloren.
Wetter.
Nacht zunächst klar, später bewölkt. Temperaturen 9 bis 5 Grad. Morgen bewölkt, im Tagesverlauf heiter 13 bis 17 Grad.
Verkehr.
A115 Dreieck Drehwitz Richtung Berlin und auch in Richtung, auch in Gegenrichtung. Zwischen Sammund und Potsdam-Wabelsberg ist noch bis 2 Uhr früh. Wegen Brückenbauarbeiten in beiden Richtungen nur eine Spur befahrbar. Zudem kommt es zu kurzzeitigen Vollsperrungen.
Frau Genehmerer mit dem Fritz-Kurzentrum.
Entschuldigung, es muss heißen... Wird präsentiert. Underworld. Samstag 15. Mai in der Columbia Halle.
Noch 25 Minuten Chaos Radio. Das ist das Wort Bildungskompetenz, oder?
Ich hab jetzt zum Beispiel so ein Zimtbuch. Das ist glaube ich robust genug. Medienkompetenz in Informationszeit, Alter.
Hätte ich das Wort Medienkompetenz immer sofort im Blickfeld gehabt. Ich bin die letzte halbe Stunde immer entsetzlich müde. Ihr müsst das jetzt alles übernehmen. Wir waren gerade schon mittendrin in der Diskussion und werden versuchen jetzt zumindest ein paar Ansätze zu liefern. In der Hoffnung, dass ihr zu Hause weiter diskutiert, vielleicht mit Lehrern diskutiert, als Lehrer mit Schülern diskutiert.
Genau, kannst du mal den Tusch spielen mit denen? Da ist irgendwo dieser Jingle da unten. Chaosradio Selbsthilfe-Tipps.
Der Chaosradio Selbsthilfe-Tipp heute mit...
Ja, also wir finden es auf jeden Fall sinnvoller, wenn ihr tatsächlich mal jetzt seid, ob ihr jetzt Schüler seid oder seid ihr Lehrer oder Lehrerin, ist auch wurscht. Jedenfalls, natürlich ist es richtig, die Politiker auf die Versäumnisse hinzuweisen, dass sie zwar Geld für die Raumreinigungskräfte, ich würde sagen Putzkolonne ausgeben, aber nicht für die Computer. Bloß, das hilft alles nicht, bis da irgendwie Gelder kommen, da seid ihr irgendwie alle schon in Rente. Sollte es das Rentensystem da noch geben.
Unser Verzweiflungseinwurf. Meistens gibt es auch kein Geld mehr für die Raumreinigungskräfte. Das ist nämlich im Sinne von Selbstversorgung, selbstverantwortlich.
Es ist auf jeden Fall prima, wenn die Lehrer, die Schüler und die Schülerinnen und Schüler, ihre Eltern auffordern, wenn da im Büro irgendwie Computer ausgemustert werden, rein in die Schulen damit, her mit dem Zeug. Das zum einen. Zum anderen, was die Betriebssystemdiskussion betrifft, haben wir das ja hier schon ein bisschen durchblicken lassen. Es gäbe halt tatsächlich Betriebssysteme, die im besten Sinne des Wortes zur Weiterbildung geeignet wären. Und Linux ist da sicherlich eine großartige Sache. Wir befürchten, es wird zu wenig Lehrer geben, die neben ihrer Entertainment-Roll überhaupt noch die Zeit, hier hatten sich da einzuarbeiten. Aber es gibt Schüler, die haben das begriffen, die haben sich nachts nicht die Fernsehprogramme reingezogen, sondern die haben sich irgendwie die Linux-Distribution reingezogen. Und die können euch das erklären. Macht sie einfach zu SysAdmins. Ey, gebt ihnen den Job. So, was haben wir denn noch? Ihr hattet da noch so einen Stapel Vorschläge hier. Vorschläge, naja klar. Ja, nee, ich meine die Medienkompetenz und nochmal diesen blöden Begriff. Wollen wir ihn nochmal beleben oder wollen wir es sein lassen?
Nein, wir waren eigentlich da, wie die Schulen sich vielleicht auch selbst helfen können und was vielleicht auch die Industrie tun kann, um den Schulen zu helfen. Also ich weiß nicht, diese Ausmusterungsgeschichte ist immer ganz schön und nett. Das Problem dabei ist, es gab ja früher auch ein paar Initiativen, wo die Schulen dann sozusagen die Entsorgung von Altgeräten übernommen haben. Und wie bei den Schulen keiner so richtig war, der irgendwie Ahnung davon hatte. Mittlerweile hat sich das rumgesprochen, dass man da schon ein bisschen aufpassen muss, dass man nicht den letzten Schrott angedreht kriegt. Schön wäre es aber auch zum Beispiel, wenn die Firmen einfach sagen, ok, Schulen sehen wir ein und da gehen wir mit dem Preis runter. Das heißt, die müssen jetzt nicht ganz so viel zahlen, als wenn eine große Firma das kauft, sondern die gehen dann mit dem Preis runter.
Das Problem ist, das sind halt Firmen. So, die wollen ihren Schulen nicht helfen, die wollen der Gesellschaft nicht helfen, die wollen Geld verdienen, deswegen machen die das. Das ist so ein bisschen das Problem.
Es gibt kein Computer im Search-Code. Es gibt auch keinen Buchverlag, der das tut, weil er unbedingt der Gesellschaft helfen will, bestimmte Bücher veröffentlicht.
Doch, es gibt von allen Buchverlagen Rabatte für Schulen. Ich bezahle für meine Kinderbücher nicht den vollen Preis, weil ich als Serierin mindestens 25% bekomme.
Ich glaube, es ist auch kein Problem, bei jedem Hardware-Hersteller der Welt irgendwie Rabatte für eine Schule zu bekommen.
Ja, das kommt aber erst langsam. Was ich nicht verstehe, ist, warum es kein Land gibt, das eben dann ein paar Tausend kauft und dann mal um Rabatt scharrt.
Das verstehe ich immer auch nicht.
Oder Schulträger. Naja, ich meine, Berlin muss ja erstmal Hauptstadt werden. Die müssen ja erstmal goldene Bürgersteige kaufen und so.
Was hat das alles gekostet?
Es gibt, ähm, es gab gerade noch eine ganz kurze Anmerkung, die müssen wir nicht weiter ausdiskutieren, aber von wegen dieser Microsoft-Diskussion meinte jemand im Chat irgendwie, dass das Problem einfach ist, dass das Problem sehr viel älter ist, das Microsoft-Problem, denn in Stellenanzeigen zum Beispiel, das kennen wir auch alle, steht definitiv drin, gefordert wird Umgang mit MS-Blah, MS-Phase, MS-Dusel. Und da sagen natürlich, deswegen gehen dann Eltern auf die Barrikaden. Das Problem also, warum man Microsoft-Produkte kennen muss, um für die Berufswelt geschult zu sein, ist sehr viel älter.
Es gibt eine schöne Alternative, vielleicht sei die hier noch mal allen ans Herz gelegt. Es gibt mindestens zwei virtuelle Machines für Linux. Das eine ist ein kommerzielles Produkt, heißt VMWare, kostet glaube ich für Schüler 99 Dollar, gibt es momentan im Beta-Test zum kostenlos downloaden. Ich weiß nicht, ich habe den Namen vergessen, möchte man einfach mal im Internet suchen. Das ist ein System, das emuliert einen Computer, das kann man unter Linux laufen lassen und auf diesem Linux emulierten Computer dann ein Windows 95, 98 oder irgendetwas installieren. Das heißt, man hat ein Linux-Betriebssystem, man hat ein vernünftiges Unix, einen Astrein-Server und auf dem läuft Word, Excel und all dieser Kompans auf der Windows.
Ja, aber Steine, das ist jetzt gerade ein technisches Lösungsmodell für ein gesellschaftliches Problem. Ich habe jetzt mal eine Frage hier an die Runde. Ist es denn tatsächlich schon so schlimm, dass die Lehrplänen der Schule und die Ausrichtung der Schulen mit Geräten sich tatsächlich nach den Stellenmarktanzeigen der Zeitung richten?
So ist das.
Das heißt, wir werden tatsächlich nur noch Arbeitsklaven produziert, oder was?
Wo sind wir denn gelandet? Das Interessante ist bei den Stellenanzeigen, wenn die Leute sagen können, na gut, ich habe zwar nicht auf Microsoft-Produkten gelernt, aus dem und dem Grund. Ich habe aber gelernt, wie eine Textverarbeitung prinzipiell funktioniert. Ich habe das an einem anderen Beispiel gelernt. Und ich weiß auch, warum ich Microsoft-Produkte nicht benutzen will. Und vielleicht kann man hier in der Firma ja auch mal drüber nachdenken. Dann werden die vielleicht ein bisschen komisch gucken, aber merken, dass der Junge oder die Frau vielleicht was auf dem Kasten hat in Richtung Computer.
Ja, aber wenn ich irgendwie in die Grundschule gehe, dann tue ich das doch nicht gleich mit der Perspektive, mich um einen Arbeitsplatz zu bewerben.
Ah nee, dann müssen wir mal einen Realitätsabgleich hinkriegen.
Ja, nein, ich meine, es soll ja sein, dass es...
Frag mal die Eltern von den Leuten, die dann die Grundschule nehmen.
Ja, Moment, ich meine, das ist ein bisschen der Unterschied. Ich hab das Glück oder weiß ich nicht, ich hab die Erfahrung, ich war sowohl auf dem Gymnasium als auch, nachdem ich da wegen zu viel Computerscheiße runtergeflogen bin, auf einer Realschule. Und was mich ein bisschen erschrocken hat, war, dass im Gymnasium, da ging es erstmal darum, zu lernen und zu begreifen und zu tun und zu machen und so fort. Und alles andere war weit weg. In der Realschule, das war dann irgendwie Mitte der Achten, da gab es irgendwie einen ganz klaren Film, den da alle gefahren haben. Wir wollen unsere Schulausbildung haben, damit wir danach eine Lehre machen können, damit wir danach einen Beruf ausüben können, damit wir danach in Rente gehen können, damit wir danach sterben können. Und das war mir ein klein wenig zu vorprogrammiert, sag ich mal. Das kommt mir ein bisschen komisch an. Das macht ja sein, dass das jetzt von mir aus überhand genommen hat und dass ich an der Stelle den Realitätsabgleich mal wieder brauche.
Nein, man muss ja auch eins mal bemerken.
Aber soll ich dann kotzen oder soll ich irgendwie?
Nein, aber Moment mal, wir müssen mal kurz einen Einschnitt machen, weil es funktioniert ja nicht so, dass man in die Schule geht und da kriegt man alles übers Leben gesagt und dann steht man im Leben. Weiß ich nicht, du hast einen Englischunterricht und da gibt es dann irgendwie die drei, vier Standard-Literaturgeschichten, die du liest und es ist dir völlig frei in deiner Freizeit oder danach oder was auch immer, dich entweder zu spezialisieren oder die gesamte Weltliteratur auf Englisch zu lesen, egal ob das, weiß ich nicht, hochliterarische Werke sind oder Pornografie. Das ist deine Entscheidung. Genauso kannst du natürlich irgendwie den Umgang mit Microsoft World in der Schule lernen und mit Linux kannst du dich jederzeit mit deinen ein bisschen Grundkenntnissen über Computer, die du dann hast, kannst du dich jederzeit beschäftigen. Also es verbietet dir ja keiner.
Ja, es verbietet keiner, aber ich werde da... Ich meine, reden wir doch mal davon, was wird denn da mit den Kindergehörn gemacht? Und wenn die tatsächlich sozusagen industriekompatibel dann nur noch zugespitzt werden, also dann ist doch irgendwie dem, was eigentlich mal das Schulwesen war, da ist doch dann überhaupt nichts mehr übrig geblieben.
Deswegen habe ich ja vor den Nachrichten versucht, darauf zurückzugehen, dass es eigentlich im Schulsystem selber seit Jahrzehnten überfällige Veränderungen gibt. Ich will doch auch die Welt verändern. Erstmal verändern.
Echt? Aber das klingt ja echt kacke.
Zum Beispiel die Idee mit dem Dreiviertelstundentakt, den die Grundschullehrerin eben hatte, das ist eine Idee, die es gibt seit Jahrzehnten. Und die ist seit Jahrzehnten obercool. Und jeder ist super stolz drauf, daß er sie macht. Ich finde es gut, wenn sie es macht. Aber das Ding ist halt, das ist keine neue Idee. Und ich denke mir einfach, das System ist relativ träge. Und das wird auch im Bezug auf Computer nicht jetzt auf einmal weniger träge werden, nur weil die Computer sich schneller verändern, als vielleicht die Pädagogik und alles andere, was mit Schule zu tun hat. Also ich denke da treffen auch wirklich zwei Welten aufeinander, die wirklich nicht füreinander geschaffen sind, so wie sie zur Zeit aufeinandertreffen.
Ja, das kann gut sein. Aber ich denke es gibt mehr Aspekte. Es gehört einfach auch dazu, dass Lehrer sein ein verdammt harter Job ist, der erstmal auch ganz viel mit Geld verdienen hat und nicht mit Berufung. Es gibt verdammt, verdammt viele schlechte Lehrer, habe ich zumindest schmerzlich erfahren müssen. Warte mal.
Okay, das nächste Lied spielen wir für die armen, armen Lehrer.
Nein, nein, nein. Worum mir es jetzt geht, ist, dass auch einfach diese ganzen Klassen zu groß sind, dass ein Lehrer überhaupt keine Chance hat ganz oft.
Aber das wurde in den 70ern auch schon diskutiert.
Naja, aber de facto ist es trotzdem so. Und dann muss man überlegen, ob man das nicht lassen muss, wenn das so nicht funktioniert. Ich meine, es führt eher zu nichts. Dann muss man halt andere Wege gehen.
Hey, wir machen eine PGO auf.
Ich finde, man müsste den Lehrern, es gibt ja auch eine ganz alte Idee, den Lehrern Noten geben. Vielleicht auf der Basis ein Lehrer, der einem Schüler eine schlechte Note gibt, gibt sie mindestens zur Hälfte sich selbst.
Ach, hippie Scheiße.
Naja, aber die Sache mit den 30 Schülern ist ja wieder so, das ist ja eine knallneue Idee, die auch, wenn wir jetzt mal die richtigen Zitate bringen, die auch diverse Bundespräsidenten regelmäßig bringen, weil man muss ja bei Projektarbeit und bei Computern und so, so viel Rechner kannst du gar nicht in den Raum stecken. Solche Räume gibt's in den Schulen nicht. Dass du jetzt 30 Plätze für 30 Schüler und noch Platz, um was daneben zu legen hast. Das heißt, um diese zwei Sachen zusammenzubringen, muss sich halt wirklich mal was ändern, oder es wird nüscht.
Also Rechner müssen kleiner werden, nicht?
Ich denke, wir machen das jetzt fertig. Wir spielen jetzt das nächste Lied für die armen, armen Lehrer.
Das klingt ja nicht armen.
Chaos Radio, die April-Ausgabe jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat hört ihr einen Blue Moon, in dem es nur um Computerthemen geht, im weitesten Sinne. Und im weitesten Sinne sag ich, war das mal technisch, mal inhaltlich.
Und heute?
Heute schwer inhaltlich, was ich halt mal sehr mag. Mit dem Chaos Computer Club, das Chaos Radio, Musik vom Analog Club DJ Team. Großartige Musik, muss ich noch mal dazu sagen. Und wir haben jetzt gerade festgestellt, dass wir noch 30.000 Sachen zu sagen haben und haben dafür noch 8 Minuten für Spaß damit haben.
Wie schaffen wir das denn? Jetzt müssen wir komprimieren. Kann mal jemand zippen?
Unsicher sicher.
Unsicher sicher, genau. Auch ganz sicher. Ein Argument. Ja, genau. Andi?
Nee, mach mal ruhig. Dann mach ich das mit dem anderen dran.
Zeit, Zeit. Es gibt noch ein Argument in der Sache, das Problem ist ja auch, dass die Lehrer und die Verantwortlichen immer Probleme damit haben, wenn Schüler da an die Sachen rangehen, dass das dann hinterher nicht sicher ist, dass sie das hacken, was nicht alles, dass da komische Sachen plötzlich passieren, Noten verschwinden und so weiter. Da muss man mal eindeutig sagen, um Microsoft Windows in irgendeiner Form im Netzwerk sicher zu bekommen, muss man sich mächtig auf die Hinterbeine stellen und schafft es doch nicht. Um Linux unsicher zu kriegen, muss man sich schon Mühe geben. So, also auch da ist der Grundsatz schon mal prinzipiell gegeben, an der Stelle fährt man mit Linux zumindest nach außen wesentlich sicherer, wesentlich besser als nach innen.
Insofern sollten die Schüler eher ein Interesse an NT haben, weil es leichter ist. Vielleicht darf man einfach der Gerechtigkeit aber nochmal sagen, dass Tim vielleicht auch wieder ein bisschen bessere Laune kriegt. Es gibt natürlich auch noch ganz andere Computer, die nicht PCs sind, sondern von Apple. Und da gibt es dann wieder ganz andere Vor- und Nachteile.
Ja, ich meine, da gibt es zwar proprietäre Systeme, aber da funktionieren die grafischen Benutzer aber vielleicht ein paar.
Ja, aber sicher sind die auch nicht.
Das ist deutlich länger.
Da können wir mal eine extra Ausgabe machen und kostenlos sind die auch nicht.
Insofern steht hier nicht zur Debatte. Die haben ein verdammt gutes Marketing, wie man Antenne mal deutlich sieht.
Naja, die haben auf jeden Fall die Entspannung.
Hey, die Aktie steigt und steigt, was bist du?
Ja, aber es geht hier ja nicht so sehr um Aktien. Also wir machen die Radiosendung jetzt nicht um den Aktienkurs des einen oder anderen Unternehmens in Höhe zu finden.
Das wäre aber auch ein spannendes Thema übrigens.
Ja, machen wir.
Apropos Aktien.
Wir machen dieses Jahr, weil wir jetzt hier nur ein paar Minuten haben, zum Beispiel noch ein paar Radiosendungen. Immer so letzten Mittwoch im Monat hier das Chaosradio. Wir machen aber vor allem im August dieses Jahr ein großes Camp. Das Chaos Communication Club findet vom 6. bis 8. August in Alt Landsberg, das ist sogar mal 20-30 Kilometer hier von Berlin, statt. Und Informationen dazu findet ihr schon jetzt unter http://www.ccc.de slash camp. Sonst könnt ihr auch einfach www.ccc.de machen und da gibt es dann irgendwie einen Link.
Genau und außerdem haben wir heute endlich die legendäre Zahl 42 erreicht im RC5-Contest, das heißt der Chaos Computer Club und alle, die da sich an diesem Projekt beteiligen, den RC5-DS-Code zu knacken.
Oder um es noch mal kurz menschenverständlich auszuwerten. Wir haben im Augenblick den Rechenexperiment teil.
Oder wir haben den 42 längsten, den schnellsten Computer der Welt. Mit all den Leuten zusammen, die sich daran beteiligen.
Als nächstes streben wir natürlich Platz 23 an und damit ihr uns da unterstützen könnt, könnt ihr unter www.ccc.de, unter RC5-Contest uns sozusagen euch den Client auch irgendwo installieren und die bei euch eventuell noch vorhandene überflüssige Rechenzeit mit in das Projekt hineingeben. Was haben wir denn noch so?
Auf dem Camp wollte ich übrigens noch kurz sagen, da werden wir natürlich auch ein bisschen Ohrtöne sammeln und so weiter.
Wir werden Radio machen alle drei Tage.
Und wir werden die ganze Zeit Radio machen. Also ich gehe im Moment immer noch davon aus, dass ich da vor Ort bin auch.
Genau. Aber mindestens. Ich dachte, ihr macht da sowieso deinen Betriebsurlaub und wir übernehmen den Sender für die drei Tage.
Ich glaube, da ist Tim noch am rotieren, wer da alles beteiligt ist und soll mich jetzt nichts vorwegnähen.
Internationale Verbreitung, bitte ich.
Nur weil du jetzt einmal in Urlaub fährst und nicht da bist, sollen wir jetzt hier einen Affen machen, ja?
Du bist immer August im Urlaub, oder was?
Das war jetzt die wichtige Information für die Hörer. Wenn ihr irgendwie möglicherweise aus welchen Gründen auch immer eher analog orientiert seid und diesen Zugang zu diesem WWW einfach noch nicht habt, dann könnt ihr auch, wir haben so eine kleine Zeitschrift, wo dann auch immer so die aktuellen Sachen drinstehen, ihr könnt für 5 Makroporto die Datenschleuder anfordern. Beim CCC-Lok-Steeterweg 72 in 20251 Hamburg.
Findet ihr aber auch alles auf dem Web?
Ja, aber wenn die kein Web haben, dann ist das ja in Ordnung.
Ich hatte gerade...
Und Analog Club findet ihr ganz bald unter www.analogclub.de Und ansonsten gibt es ja auch noch das Chaos-Updips, also den Chaos-Radio-Ticker.
Und da gibt es dann auch noch ein paar Infos über die Sendung, was wir heute noch so gehabt haben, ein paar URL, die wir hier auf den Zetteln haben, die wollen euch natürlich auch noch zu kommen, dass ihr auch schön hinterherklicken könnt.
Mir fällt da gerade noch was ein, Aktien. Wir hatten vorhin das Thema Aktien. Wie wär's denn, um mal kurz zum Thema zurückzukommen, wenn man eine Aktie von einer Schule erwerben kann und dann von den Schülern, die hinterher ja ins Berufsleben gehen, 0, 01% ihres Gehaltes sozusagen als Dividende gezahlt bekommt. Ich bin sicher, das reicht völlig aus, um damit beliebig teure Computer an diesen Schulen zu finanzieren.
Und wonach richten sich der Aktienkurs nach den Noten, die die Leute haben?
Na ja, mal gucken zum Beispiel. Oder irgend so ein Konzert. Da müsste man mal drüber nachdenken.
Die müssen alle mit einem T-Shirt an. Es ist aber nicht so weit, dass hier die Lehrinhalte von Industrieunternehmen gesponsert werden. Also insofern, wenn man sich Amerika anguckt, dann weiß man, dass mit den Schulen und dem Bildungswesen, das kann man noch viel, viel schlimmer treiben.
Also in Mexiko wird übrigens gerade staatlich Linux eingesetzt.
Das ist eine Erprägung der West-Universität.
In anderen Bundesländern erschießen sich die Schüler gegenseitig, weil sie irgendwie noch ganz andere Werkzeuge von zu Hause empfohlen bekommen. Obwohl das nicht lustig ist.
Naja, Realität.
Sarkasmus ist auch eine Form von Horror.
Gut, was haben wir jetzt noch? Wir haben noch zwei Minuten.
Wir wollten noch ein bisschen über diese Zukunftsvision sprechen.
Hey, Zukunftsvision, wow! Die Lehrer, die Lehrer brauchen wir nicht?
Das geht jetzt wirklich nicht mehr in zwei Minuten.
Ich hab hier noch absurde Papiere. Die Informationstechnik und das Internet. Nein, ich zitiere jetzt nicht nochmal her.
Die große Frage, eigentlich wollten wir mindestens die letzte halbe Stunde, nämlich die Frage diskutieren mit euch zusammen natürlich. Brauchen Schüler überhaupt noch Lehrer? Das fällt jetzt flach.
Braucht Lehrer überhaupt noch Schüler?
Genau, braucht ihr uns?
Brauchen wir dich? Alles klar, Mama lala ey.
Das war's im Jahre 1993.
Fischmob unter der Leitung von Bollesnüter, Dänemark.
Hallo, ich wünsche mir Frogger von der Gruppe Atari.
Martin Pedersdorf hat mich gebeten noch anzusagen, dass vorher morgen ab dem geht. Nein, wer jetzt die Musik, die ganze Zeit die drei Stunden vom Analog-Team irgendwie sehr mochte, dem sei empfohlen, morgen im Schizo-Tempel, mein Fachstammladen sozusagen, hab neulich ne Kneipe gesehen, die heißt Zweiter Wohnsitz, ist ein großartiger Name, im Schizo-Tempel morgen, der Riga, Straße 77, gibt's ne Techno-Party, ab wann? So, ab 10 in dem Dreh. Schizo-Tempel, Riga, Straße 77, wer das alles mochte, der kann morgen das Analog-Team dort hören. Achso, und viel Spaß mit Martin, der macht jetzt den Night Flight.